ORN you guys now if I have to go oh you
gotta get over those you know if I step
away from my cooking that I'm doing all
we are live welcome to the iron Lords
podcast episode number 46 and it's
another glorious Sunday and we are back
at the roundtable on the Lord's Day
we've got two very special guests pub G
milestones December MP Dino's Nintendo's
mini direct some great in quantum dream
allegations to development update to
discuss so we're gonna get right into it
I want to introduce a Lord whose debut
at the round table has been long overdue
for some time this Lord is not only an
Army veteran sharpshooter and protector
of the realm in real life he's also one
of the top PvP players in the game and
is always willing to help a fellow
Channel five clan member do any destiny
raid
introducing the channel 5 OG an FPS guru
the lord with the most diabolical laugh
in the game making his debut into the
realm of the lord all three years of
doing all that negates we have over 20
years of love
so you know I'm not gonna get into our
personal on their own the former all the
bad GG front but let you know that
you're not safe anywhere you know that
connect bike because we all used to
suffer the party check welcome you a lot
of people already know who nonsense it
is like I said I mean he's a mainstay in
clan and open games and is it we would
try to get over so lucky
he's more kognito than kinda good to
have you we have Lord who was no
stranger to the ILP and its roundtable
royalty this Lord has supported the ILP
from day one and I always look forward
to breaking bread with him and each and
every Guardian con for spirited gaming
and destiny discussions introducing the
nightfall soloist the cayde-6 stash
finder and fellow switch gang member the
Lord who's one of the most positive
beacons in the Destiny community and can
still chef up some of the best cheese
cakes you've ever seen back to the realm
of the Lord's Bobby Lord Bacchus how you
doing sir all doing pretty good thank
you for the intros and by the way yea if
you haven't got one of those intros
before you can't live up to them so I
just kind of like everybody else kind of
riding the roller coaster so they can
have its ups and downs to say they
absolutely some things good to have you
back you know we're gonna get into that
destiny talk much later into the show
but uh we got a lot to discuss so of
course we have the usual suspects at the
round table our calls with the Como's
will be joining us in progress courtesy
of his new spanking new job of
employment
we'll [ __ ] hopefully sick so he could
agree with lucky but of course we have
our most technical gaming Lord the solo
gamer who lives for the single player
selfish experience semi offline profile
Illuminati my baby
Lord sovereign are you doing sir do a
fantastic man and doing great
no I have been anybody get a little
gaming in you know I'm saying finally
coming closer to finishing some of these
games that I had since November
no orcas lowly but doing it looking
forward to long weekend of course we
have the excess game oh the lord of
combat sports who was a man of his
convictions and demands nothing less
than that premium experience
Oh beloved Lord King we know exactly
what's going on everybody I hope
everybody had a glorious week I had a
glorious week and I just wanna say there
was no combat sports this weekend which
is really strange I mean it wasn't minor
combat sports here and there like a
little minor MMA shows going Jeremy
Stephens vs. choy O Lord that Bella door
no this is UFC Fight Night tonight they
probably spent a long weekend
Oh for free yeah yeah definitely check
whatever sports one Choi Choi had an
amazing fight with um with Cub Swanson
last year I mean that was like a fight
of the Year candidate even not winning
fight of the year oh yeah this is this
is either gonna be a quick knockout Oh
knock-down drag-out my round up so I
look for knockout Drago I want to see
that I want to see that this is what
y'all understand is that these IOP dudes
we talk fighting we live eat and breathe
this so you just think it's just me it
is something you constructed
oh I am a minor cog in this great
machine without Lord addicts very
condescending start out - Lord drew said
f5 never worked on me bro that put a
fight we had this week I want you to
understand Goldberg still rocks the boat
you never had a win after day to give
you some context we used to be heavy
into the WEF wrestling games back in the
day and we got our boy on Twitter he's
to be a big huge Brock Lesnar fit so
like back in those days he black boxes
he was such a dominant character that
when he gets you in his super what's
over so like you would read the day when
you hear you say f5 cuz you knew one
year I believe is when Goldberg cave was
the today WWE and he was like a lock
character and I believe like a boxer and
a Lord King made a trade right right I
had to rock and Lloyd top box who wanted
the rock because we had drafts WCW NWO
revenge's to go yes again this was post
we had to find a wrestling game like all
the ackee games they stopped making them
so this was like going to xbox at the
time so they've made that fateful trail
or archive boxes like a rock for
Goldberg right
we gave the most dominant character
looking with four moms we Goldberg we
could not beat him he would kick out of
your super it was it was so such a
government performance and they're like
what's he got a hold of Brock which is a
Lord Drew's character like it was over
it was it was hilarious those are
memories so we got him literate and it
was real funny to see them go back and
forth
it was a one o'clock in the morning lord
Cognito random tweet that started the
mess so fast back you to chat what's up
man looks Iike sium everybody your net
talking i came and talked so of course
yeah it's lord Cognito here spreading
that gaming realness on the IOP i'm
telling you what you want to hear but
you need to hear so obviously you know
we got a lot to discuss we want to get
into what the lords are playing this
week so let's start with the guests
let's start with our debut channel 5
Lord Lord said where have you been
playing this weekend a little bit of
fortnight what you been rocking yeah
I've been doing a little bit of
fortnight a little bit of pub G a little
bit of the Batman it was on sale a
little bit of Destiny cuz you know I
never put it down even wearing our slump
I don't put it down just I had to get
the you know the stuff done regardless
segi Rachelle's done she's in the bag
she's in the bag stop causing trouble
with that damn Ark I'm gonna play it
with you soon you don't have to put me
on blast I know he's the only one on my
list playing that's all I've been
playing I just put playing you know the
casual stuff I've been hearing they're
trying to catch up lord ebon tiss what
have we been playing this week besides
of course always a little destiny in
there the videos got to keep going
Pub G is kind of the big one also as
well with the new to recently do it it's
just that's the one that almost pisses
you off the move number two solo hurts
so close generous I had like the upper
ground and it was like me behind a rock
and him behind a hill and it was beat
peak peak peak and I lost so I was just
like damn
like clubbed you if it's been more kind
of digesting kind of the anxiety in the
whole community over destiny - and then
between them work mostly those two and
working on a couple big videos for for
one my big pc rig that i built recently
I sent you that picture so yeah so I
slice yes that's been like tweaking and
overclocking and benchmarking and all
that stuff so it's been a lot of that
too so so we got some big big things
cooking up with that uh that PC set up
that rig set up going on oh yeah so just
kind of going into yeah looking at the
Elgato 4k and stuff like that should
capture the 1440p like it might have a
double PC set up things like that might
be working so yeah and PC destiny - is
it's a different animal have you played
it
yeah looking at trying to coerce me that
evil won't rank you yeah you're gonna be
like how much how do I make this happen
where's what wallet just take it just
take the wallet it's a different game on
there but I mean PC in general so like
pub G's running but as good as they can
I've got Assassin's Creed that kind of
came with in the parts I've got that was
kind of work through it came for free
and then picked up the division a little
bit because it was on sale so I was
gonna jump back in and check that a
little bit you know update for the
decision out her to which everybody say
like those positive things it's really
good to know like if it's gonna
completely fix it but yeah it's like it
was worth checking out it was like 25
bucks for the whole thing on the Steam
sale so like sure gosh you know Lord
sovereign what have we been catching
this week I love to cross games so they
had a pickup to go I have a dis da I
love pick Ross
chuckle to myself Meat Boy super meat
workers I that's me that's the perfect
for the fifth time you know what I
picked it up at lunch on the 360 and I
never really played it because this is
that played a little bit other guys cool
but I those the game those things I
never really wanted to play on my TV so
now I have the perfect place to play
we'll get into that little boy and let
me see now on console I just been trying
to get to that Wolfenstein rumors that
that game goes places Oh Lord that game
so I'm assuming you're after that
partway which I put in pretty changing
in the narrative that was an O ish part
yes yes I got to we need to tell me
about it but he told me I would get to a
part that it would literally flip the
game over so yeah it does that and then
after that it really really goes left in
some crazy directions and but to me the
coolest part about it is the
interactions between the characters the
characters are so well written and so
deeper you care about them you really
care about this going on with them and
that's what surprised me most about the
new order when it came out was like wow
these characters are really fleshed out
and they just it just continued it so I
can't wait to finish it hopefully finish
it within a couple of days nice nice
look King what have we been touching
this week okay we got covered about what
I got my chicken dinner this week yes it
was me Mason and a random yeah it was me
Mason at random and it just went down we
definitely held it down Mason went down
he was the last person well the first
person I've spotted to go down and it
was me in a random just holding down the
situation and it got to a point where we
just kind of worked it out in the bushes
and heat the random knew about some
weird rock and we weren't in chat with
each
the boys like somebody cold we went
back-to-back it was just then we finally
hooked up in the chat with the random
after the fact and I just met a new
friend on Xbox oh you know that
Wolfenstein are you started let me
explain if you have an Xbox one X if you
have an Xbox if you have a Playstation
if you have a pro if you have a PC buy
the game it's a game that one child
someplace it's going to change their
life right it's going to be some child
is gonna pick that game up this this is
this is a note in gaming history mmm
where a child is going to get a
different perspective on life and he's
gonna get courage from the game because
the game is gonna give the marriage to
confront certain things in life then
goes in places where movies goals with
book goals where conversation deep
conversations go mom I'm so proud as a
gamer to have played the game to play it
all the way through I actually watched
the credits roll because I wanted to
give the just due to in every last
person who had anything to do with this
game on any level so I wanted to sit
there and watch the names be rolled up
because they deserved that much from the
musical score to the graphics to the to
the content to the delivery and like you
said the interaction in between each
character is so beautiful and so done
well that you wouldn't believe this came
from a mindless first-person bitmap yeah
did you know the history of Wolfenstein
right I see where it's evolved to it's
pretty look a little egg ready to chase
how they tell you do that look look look
there please Todd house praise God how
just dismiss truth anchorman bethesda
took a stance and I'm pretty sure that
the corporate dude is like we will
won't go there we won't go there and I'm
glad we're as a gaming community we're
moving forward please buy Detroit
please buy these games that are pushing
these boundaries I've also started zero
horizon doing horizon zero doing
whatever I got a set of package with a
little flu inside for me because that
game also attacks some biasness and
stuff like that that you know kids may
come furniture in life so but trust me
this game is definitely worth whatever
you pay for it absolutely it is a
fantastic game completely agree Lord
addict what's going on the co-host with
the code mouths my brother from another
mother and the how of the young wolf my
lord addict what have you been playing
sir pug G jus number pub G all day every
day
you haven't planted a lot like a lot a
lot like I've like seven chicken women
do your chest out real strong he says I
feel good - yesterday back to back put
some do that a sniper on the ridge that
like me and uh mean Timmy just could not
leave the house like he had no that was
the squad Lord Jensen Lord John was no
chance to know me and uh John almost got
a couple but its vainly being me Timmy
and uh and uh
Timmy's Frannie I see Timmy like lay out
three or four people with a pistol no
doubt that's what Sub Pop G's out here
man I respect it
yes for me Lord you know it's actually
been a lot of stuff going on a personal
level stuff to take care of so it's been
a little little rough but um just trying
to I've been doing a little I've been in
my lord sovereign bag like kind of the
offline Illuminati single-player mode
- social steals everything constraint
now but I actually been going through my
uh my ps4 backlog and I actually started
the actual Street Fighter 5 I was
attacking that touch that Bob laughing
okay I was having fun with that some
weird little character who looks like
Strider Hyrule from like the 8-bit
Genesis game but he's like old and then
when you play with him he's got a move
that makes him young like a ninja
Strider I don't know some weird
character forgot his name I was playing
with him and then I'm touching actually
I'm gonna laughs I was touching no man's
sky on first time it's way better yeah
yeah I've been touching that for the
first just to see what it was about
I never by guess I never got a chance to
pick it up play it the sale like I said
was not that long ago right after the
videogame was like really cheap so I
said let me do that
you know Xbox I still have got a chance
to touch the pub G since the latest
update there's been a lot going on I'll
get to that and I destiny - I've been
just been messing around a little
disappointed I've ever since uh mayhem
laughs he bounces so they know just
leave it in there no I had so much fun
in PvP just you know doing my own thing
and being able to roam around with my
super and not have to follow the team
and a little bit like Oh destiny win but
you don't have to follow sinister
everywhere you have to follow everybody
had a chance to sign it wasn't everybody
got their supers at the same time but we
can save this for later so I didn't
played mayhem and destiny - everyone
gets a super at the same time no
normally in crucible like everybody
tends to get it around the same time in
a normal match in crucible it's just
coming up in or and mayhem it's coming
up all the time so they're just all over
the place anyway obviously it's fun that
was I thought that was a cooler cost
everyone get they super at the same time
many noble balls are gonna clash
together
when you've been I know you've been on
your destiny strike but it that was the
funnest period of destiny when the
dawning happened they had ma'am and they
made you do it as part of the quest line
for the dawning every day when you log
you know every reset it was so much fun
man I was rocking my own bus my skull of
diorama car so I can get more noble
balls I always have fun man for the
Warlock to do absolutely love I was out
enjoying I having a good time with that
switch I see me man and this is the
police's a long game I'm passing some
pretty disturbing he says something
about interrogations he's too tough to
interrogate let the beatings begin to
that effect that he was going to be
torture it was crazy
game is introducing mechanics I'm like
3/4 of the way into the game that
introduced because I've never seen
before so I'm like normally when you do
a police investigation you know it's
like the dude on the bottom level you
know he's like the low-level Street guy
you try to get him the snitch and then
he'll give up people who consider who go
up the ladder till you get to the actual
crime boss crime head but this time it
was like yeah he's not cooperating so
you want to interrogate torture
waterboarding physical bodies that's why
I love this game like the fact that
Nintendo co-signers you shout the weapon
studios we even reach out they reach
back out to me we're gonna have them
more shortly well let the Lords know cuz
I have to talk to them about the writing
and I gotta talk to them about the pitch
to the Nintendo switch in DT and how
a would successfully pull this which
everything is available dark says is
like gory but man this game is just like
hitting on a different level switch
after dark tweets frame buddy go get
into the box real quick real quick
I'm sorry got to mention one thing that
I'm playing and I want to talk about it
quick because so absolutely go for some
come down to two weeks I was in the open
beta for Dragon Ball fighters II oh my
lord
listen I haven't watched raggin Ball Z
in years I don't know what's going on in
the lore I don't know what the hell is
happening I really don't I don't touch
that but just from an aesthetic point of
view the fact that it's Arc System Works
making this game these guys know how to
make fighting games ring yeah I've
always felt like when you talk about
blades blue you talk about guilty gear
and this these games have always been
like in terms of style in terms of
aesthetic in terms of like systems in a
lot of ways they kind of beat Street
Fighter and Capcom like a more
interesting they're more interesting and
they've taken Dragon Ball universe this
game is gorgeous look or or just be
prepared for a guilty gear versus Dragon
Ball Z oh my lawful I'm hearing some bad
things about the server's door okay I'm
gonna be a hundred I've gone in I have
not been able to have a have a versus
match so far yeah like people talk about
they can't even get in and they ain't
worried cuz this thing releases in like
what two weeks or something yeah so
they're worried about that it could just
be you know super server Overlord people
want to get in on that
like its kind of crazy there are a lot
of people online that's it's a little
disturbing cannot get it right so
hopefully they rectify that but I was
able to play at least the training mode
which lets you get in there and touch
the game and see it so this is where my
experiences coming from oh I got to tell
you man like they they get it down pat
it is such a gorgeous game to play long
systems wise like all like all the
supers and everything just looks so much
like the show um if you're a fan of this
if you're just a fan of pretty games
like it's one of those games you can't
really overlook it's that pretty long
and it plays beautifully so it's gonna
be a matter of you know for me like if
the story mode is cool um and what sort
of stuff they get into it from what I've
been seeing in trailers like they're
really getting into they really gonna
give you like the short version of
what's been happening in the actual
story so if you're kind of behind on
that you'll get a version of that and
hopefully hopefully the the online and
holds up don't cut the game is gorgeous
again what's good man shut up - uh
Marcus offered actually doing a promo on
that and getting that on their stage you
know that's gonna big for them my
Japanese standpoint yeah the game was
good it was good let's see so well let's
get into it we got the poll result from
last week they're in and the people have
spoken to the question in the current
resolution era of gaming with 1080p vs
720p and now true 4k versus dynamic
checkerboard in 4k our gaming executives
wrong for engaging their fan base on
social media with these subjects the
winner at 46% and a very funny
three-way il people is the know it's all
marketing by execs why are you mad at a
surprising second place at 28% was that
I don't care my side always wins group
the shallow gamers were definitely in
the building for the second place and at
their place at 26 percent was the yes
it's done in bad taste by executives
that executives need to do better so
thanks to all who participated in last
week's poll what do the Lords think
about this is start with our guest Lord
sinister we feel about this you feel you
know execs micro Mike Ibarra and Phil
and these guys and angry Brooks
shouldn't be typing up the resolution
get they got to do their good job that's
how they got to do their job and they're
not gonna stop
they you're not gonna stop just because
you know people are up
that they got to market it they got a
cell they got to make their money no
doubt no doubt the people who people
seem to agree Lord Ibanez will you feel
about this whole resolution Aaron
executives getting hands on or social
media well I mean yeah I kind of took
the words out of my mouth there but it's
like I mean they're they're still there
to sell a product I mean they have a
business to do so I mean just the fact
that if they have something that they
can push say it's Xbox one X is like
native 4k over the checkerboarding or
vice versa whatever you're gonna do
I mean they've just that's their turn
it's like - I think for them to get in
there honestly it's refreshing because
to see executives actually say things
same was like separate example but like
you know if Christopher Baird a game
director saying pretty like candid
things on Twitter about a game when they
say like hey we tried this thing it was
buggy we're trying something else they
don't most people are not that candid so
honestly I just appreciate the honesty
and openness of any of all this stuff
I'd rather have more of that in the
future so bring it on no doubt no doubt
any other lords wanna chime in before we
move on about that poll oh good I mean I
appreciate I appreciate the fact that
some some developers take the
opportunity to be able to talk more
candidly about their games which is
something we don't see we never really
see um but they're like again the the 4k
talk and stuff that is marketing stuff
and that is their job and it's their job
to get you interested in you know
whatever the company line is at the
moment I hear people like be upset like
you know Aaron Greenberg ain't such a
shill like he's paid to be a shield
description I'm sure he's very
enthusiastic about what he does loves it
is his job to make the moment he's not
asked about his looks less true that we
have a problem with no doubt the kid you
get on Google it takes me into places
with friends I I got jump into these
topics but uh we got a new segment fresh
off the presses
breaking news actually debuted this
morning and definitely wanted to address
shout-out to Lord Sam tobert a couple of
people brought to my attention while Tim
dog also the super deformed gamecast
crew check them out to a good I believe
was Thursday not blossom tales death but
needless to say uh this one is a little
interesting this is from Quantic Dream
and if you don't know those are guys
with a purse behind heavy rain clean on
two souls and the other game that I'm
excited about Detroit becomes human so
it looks like what was that was ELISA he
says okay so pretty much it looks like
their arm the verbs have been accused of
inappropriate behavior over working
staff colluding or at least turning a
blind eye to a schoolboy culture
involving sexist and racist jokes so I'm
at for their party looks like age and um
I can't pronounce these guys I'm just
gonna say Guillaume Kevin ounce his last
name he's the other damn looks like they
denied all the allegations saying that
they're very surprised and shocked by
this and it looks like um there's whole
bunch of Photoshop images that were
leaking out there you know a lot of
crazy stuff with a lot of people who
worked on the game and collaborators and
section positions homosexual slurs
even made up to look like Nazi so um
this is running rampant obviously you
know it's a very controversial subject I
don't know we've had this discussion
before on ILP where we talked about you
know what do we feel if a game developer
you know look they I know you up you're
read your child every day developer for
somebody that you like you've had this
poll before you know they do something
or you hear something unethical or
sexual or something to that effect about
said game you know would this prevent us
you know from buying the game and I know
this is especially interesting to me it
hits home for me because uh as y'all
know I'm a huge Detroit became human
I'm a fan boy becoming you now
so as you have a few fanboy for this
game is one of my most anticipated
PlayStation titles next to like God of
War and shin hwal so I'm gonna bring
this to the round table now that we hear
this stuff about Quantic Dream and these
allegations Oh normally I would give it
to my guest first but I'm gonna give it
to King like I said before I said it a
million times you vote with your wallet
you go inside to store it like if you
feel appalled about certain things if
you have been a subject of being
ridiculed and you've been tortured in a
manner that you felt that these people
is being tortured listen they were in
the work environment the work
environment was kind of lackadaisical
this is what I'm taking from the
situation I did not work there this is
all alleged and they had jokes you have
your little frat groups you have your
little groups that you sit down you make
jokes we make jokes inside our our
gaming rooms there in a gaming
environment so I don't think is anything
different than maturing the game as it
goes along so they're they're having the
same conversations we're having been
doing the same things that we're doing
and if somebody takes offense to certain
things like certain people get pointed
out and get picked out to be joked upon
to be trolled upon it used to be a rite
of passage before that you made it out
of the joke and you made it out of the
troll earlier I remember that joke that
we had now these dudes got these tiki
torches out here and they're like stop
trolling me and they get a group all the
trollers not they don't want to be
trolled and they're sitting there like
we're gonna rage against the machine
everything is a problem mm-hmm it's not
a problem okay let me ask you this quick
question before I give it to wrestler
also um you know obviously they're
trying to say that these two at the top
are kind of providing like this very
this negative culture and like hitting
also it is all besides the emails that
went out and this is like a this is like
an email that was internal among you
know the collaborators on the game there
was also allegations of you know these
guys at the top you know targeting
forming from employees with sleazy
behavior hitting on and pushing physical
kisses and
because Lord kibosh was in the chat and
um we're big fans Marvel heroes right
and Marvel heroes as you know came out
if it was on PC for so long we've been
praying for the day comes a concert it
comes to console
we're all happy and the little son the
devil the development on the game stops
and next thing you know the game shut
down so we'd start being kibosh we do
some digging and come to find out the
guy on the top things and I cannot
comment about to say is that pretty
people and I get called out so I'm
really feeling that this dude is really
ugly at the top cuz how'd he look like
bread somebody nobody is squealing oh
stop it which is where I wanted to go I
I understand what you you're handsomer
snuggly hug
was that like [ __ ] is it fair that
collaborators on a game who worked and
put a lot of hours on a game like it's
something like Detroit you know have you
rained all these games right and unless
they find out that the top the heads are
actually the ones that are engaging in
is it fair to penalize the whole studio
is this something that's like no you
know I don't want anything to do with
them the whole game as as a fact so like
where where you at with that and where
the rest of the lords at Detroit I mean
I don't think it's fair to penalize the
entire the entire studio because these
people that are having these issues are
the ones that have worked on this game
or are working on this thing I think you
get to a certain point where David case
maybe needs to reevaluate who's in front
of this game and when their interviews
and whatnot maybe you need to take a
step back and work on what's wrong with
this studio at a fundamental level we're
not worried about me worried about being
the face of it because and maybe put
these other people that are deserving
upfront and handle those underlying
issues I'm gonna say this right now like
we could make sure we can make jokes in
our groups and that's one thing when I
talk about a professional work
environment okay what's your point that
has no place there it has no it's the
sexism
it's the harassment and it's not only
just no jokes you know we can't well
this wasn't sexual ooh boxing wasn't
sexual but we were when when Star Wars
came under fire we thought for sure that
was gonna hit and then low and behold
MPD came around let's get you in yeah
this but what's to get in like there's
nothing like you know as much as I hate
to say it you know these people could
say well it depends on who it is like
you gotta have a certain car to get away
with some dumb [ __ ] okay like if if I
don't know what's a bad game if the
people who made Just Cause came out and
said some light you know racist slurs
and you know say white people are like I
don't know who I ain't even really going
into that but whatever it's like even if
they did it I'm like I don't even care
but like because that came out there is
said like it called me every white
racial slur you could think of I'm like
I'm still buying yeah
all right so let me let me let's play
devil's advocate Lord addict what would
it take them for you to not buy again
from from like what what's the line
drawn basically come here and put harm
to my family open the David Cajun to
show my brother a few dozen times like I
still might buy they game before it's
got the proceeds got to go to the Church
of Satan children working on the game
like you know 23 hours a day like no it
really has to be something like that
again like they're there they represent
some organization that is hell bent on
murdering maybe it the whole company was
like these are the two top guys these
are the quantum were you I'm exactly
where room is depends how thick skin or
how thin-skinned you are if you can if
you could give it out and you see it
take it so we want a party what if you
want a party of I'll or podcast people
on Xbox what if this is affecting you as
it is and again I don't apologies to
anyone in the chat I'm not trying to
make this political right Lord sister I
know how you feel you served your
country you're very passionate you know
about patriotism
and when you see things in Miss Justice
obviously you know we know you don't
agree with certain aspects of I'm just
gonna leave it at that
now let's come now let's just say that
the game which you loves like this or
some new games you really passionate
about you come to find out that the
proceeds are going there or he said
person that you don't like this figure
president's figure is behind this is Co
siding this will then will you not
purchase that game if it's a we don't
even know if some of these proceeds are
going on pc i just wanna Microsoft all
that money's going over there score Enix
people like that japanese developer
saying i don't like anyone that's not
agent i want to genocide the rest of my
relation and then they're like but this
final fantasy says it's like whoa you
know we know you i can't do that because
somebody a little more high horse over
here mr. cogito are you buying detroit
sir yes I am thank you that's enough
said topic closed we all feel the same
exact way I mean this hypocrisy at its
finest nothing is gonna stop you from
doing
and engaging and what you want to engage
with I don't care
I don't care what is attached to you no
trust me when I tell you this I don't
buy a temple and sneakers because of
something that the temple and owner said
against minority and Lord King remember
also funny you said that remember when
Chris Tao came out right Chris that was
like here we don't really appreciate the
urban markets but if they had the
special cranberry juice flavor that is
only exclusive to them and they got
cranberry juice and it tastes like I
can't imagine I'm going to have to buy
those analogies three there's not two
different Skyrim's there's once card you
could buy brands of shoes you are
different a little bit but there's not
one there's not like a North American
sky or in the South American sky laughs
are you back sir this lordy box is back
we got your viewers little skewered cuz
that but this is the police game when it
made me have to make the choice between
working with the Mafia cuz the police
stations that the government wanted me
to get the black people out of the out
of the appreciate I had to turn off the
game after that I was like in order to
get rid of the black figure I had said
one black detective or three black cops
into a setup for them to die then I had
no black you and then the bull
over here talking about the narrative it
said gay but instead of firing them
Alice I you want to kill them if I fired
them I lose I lose like a standing with
my peoples so I gotta like figure out a
way and the only way to do it was you
know talk to the Mafia set up a hit fake
you handle [ __ ] and then have a certain
minority white will boycott for loot
crate's but we won't boycott boycott
like three things couple minutes ago I'm
walking around wearing your brand and
I'm promoting your brand I'm playing
your game in the comfort of my home
nobody seen when I'm door he bounces his
back once I see you said you back at the
chat yep sorry all right here we come
did you see maybe I get a little voice
of reason or just said some crazy stuff
a bungie about racial things offended
everyone you know everyone you love but
they like put that death City three
dropping next week I said what you Lions
would you buy it so basically what's
happened Laurie bounces is that David
cage and quantum dream have been accused
of all this inappropriate behavior had
the people who make in Detroit became
human these the ones that made how heavy
rain so uh basically this is Holi coming
out with images you know very sexual
very racially charged images also um
they've been actually one of them has
actually been accused of actually
physically hitting on the employee
sleazy behavior um parties and kids you
know hitting on staff at parties and
pushing tissues on them and stuff like
that now that the devs have come out and
denying it they've said that nothing's
happened at this that someone's making
this up but obviously it's it's
allegations in the early stage so what
we bring in to you Lord about this is if
your favorite name or in this case you
know saying with Quantic Dream if this
happens to you is we had this ILP poll
before it was it was charged up right
and hey let me let me ask this is a
factor allegation right now its
allegation okay it's allegation but um
let's just say deej Christopher Barrett
bigot could out there accusing of
groping up you know whoever at the
Bungie functions let's just say that
let's apply this to Bungie which we know
is your heart would that stop you from
picking up destiny three I guess would
also depend on the action if there was
proof like okay they're out there out
there out the images have been somebody
often obviously if they were going to
take the money they were willing to shut
up
we'll see this is this is my whole thing
to it right nobody is saying when Tom
Cruise goes around and kisses people on
the cheek inside the club we're back
when he was younger you know
body says anything you know when Tom
goes round Wow when he was at the height
of his risky business remember that
nobody nobody say anything when he's at
the height of his but maybe my people
might complain now his old body now but
I'm talking about them you know nobody
say anything with the handsome person
doing it but when these ugly people is
out here for cell phone people oh this
is outrageous outrage but handsome
people get away with certain things this
is what I'm trying to tell you it's Fame
hate or outrage stop stop rough one like
if it was just in the moment at that
point I mean if I'd already pre-ordered
okay I guess let me let me state this
bungees a 500-person studio okay 497
other people within that's what I was
going so it worked their ass in my mind
and that's the point where it's like
that's why it was like when you say if
they're not gonna do anything it's like
do I agree with what you know those
dozen or but do I want to support a
studio where there's 497 other people
that do amazing things and there's 3
decisions I don't agree with that's
where I'm torn because there are good
things it's like you know from a
corporate side do you agree with these
pieces and that's why that's why it's
like it's a tough thing it's like do I
want to enjoy the game that all these
other people get did you know extreme
work on but do I support like the crap
that they're doing never of course not
so much on the White House like lawn
that is expressed of the I hope you are
not necessarily opinions of everyone
associated with anybody behind me when
I'm running through the fire allow me to
get due to fire on my own
but I do say this y'all thinking it I
missed it so were you guys just like
comes out on Tuesday I'm cancelling it
I'm done we're you guys agreement with
you I mean I'm still picking up
everybody I had it from this again this
is my moral conquer so what I look at it
is that okay I'm not gonna penalize the
actions you know for to for the whole
entire studio that worked on the game
now yes they are at the top I mean we
can't deny that the two that are being a
cute little bit to mantain child among
us and in each ad he's like I'm not
telling you what to buy not to buy but
just not the print pretend as a small
issue completely not trying to pretend
this a small issue this is a very big
issue and no one's trying to know don't
know it's not a smaller that's why I
said if it's true lock them up right
exactly
right but at the same time what I what
I'm trying to get at is that there's
this coach and this is where I agree
with looking there's this culture
because you morally disagree with the
actions of people in a company that
because they choose to boycott said
product that they try to guilt you also
into boycotting said product and you
can't do that if someone wants to buy
it's the same thing with the loot
crate's is the same thing with any
window if you want to buy it that's your
choice you know I'm saying but you have
to respect it as far as both side that's
what I was pretty much respected on both
ends and also listen when you're not in
a situation if something's being told to
you abused something on a piece of paper
it sounds a lot more horrible when you
read something or you hear it secondhand
then it's actually in the moment or
whatever happens you understand so we
don't know really
in what context certain things was being
said and and what context certain things
was being done right we weren't there
and unless you look at a videotape or
some apne not to be honest with you is
really dirty it is really mucky but if
you're asking my personal opinion I'm
buying Detroit and I'm probably gonna
get the deal see now
with the laws we got little sidebar here
it's just gonna one of those things like
this stuff about Kevin Spacey go for it
I was like so that's like a tough one
then you have the stuff like louis c.k
came out and all that stuff one thing I
must say this I must say this children
and people that are not enable of to
consent to anything that's a crime and
it should be locked up 100%
I'm down with locking them up people are
being locked out but you know I mean I
was just like the topic can keep going
and it's just kind of their different
degrees and things like that and
variations and none of us are there and
when allegations come up later on it's
like yeah there's so many variants to
this and the cut but then you see on
Twitter it's like somebody's like well
you're here when Tom Cruise is like 80 a
piece where you see on Twitter girls
like you know well this is the reason
why people don't come out when it's like
somebody who accused I forget what
politician then all the sudden our house
is set on fire and there's like an arson
investigation you're like they don't
count em out about it so there's so much
when you're not in a circle it's like
until all the facts are out that's why
it's hard allegations are annoying
because the Internet's full of the PBS
even though the pictures are out there
shopping yeah but uh we're gonna move on
Lord that was a bonus one I had to throw
it on it was hot off the presses
breaking news what we gonna move this
thing on Nord addict Xbox got some
things to be feeling good about pop G
what's going on sleep a little bit looks
like a pop g passes three million
players on Xbox one and angry first to
put this out this chest was out very
strong this week by the way you had a
lot of interesting tweets this week so
um it looks like the team need to
continue to improve the in-game
experience
pero all shout out to a lord addict he's
coming back he's computers are forcing
update yeah I had that thing happened to
me too it's crazy
Windows trying to force an update I
think that meltdown thing is going
around so they're trying to get people
to restart there now but back to the
subject in here with a pub gee yeah so
it looks like I said because a debuting
an Xbox one preview program you know
it's been a huge success jacked growing
community and so on and so forth and I
just want to bring this to the Lord's
this is addicts topic in reference to
pub G passing three million players on
Xbox one more eve on ttis how do I mean
hey Congrats
I mean more power to him enjoy the game
it's kind of a it's a unique animal and
obviously it's kind of set wildfire to
the gaming community of everybody's
gonna try and copy it paladin's has
theirs coming next and yeah um so I have
an issue like the whole hero shooter
thing breaks I think this whole idea of
like everybody's the same you find
you're looting stuff but no I mean the
success is really cool from what I've
heard on normal Xbox though it's garbage
now has the place that made know just
like the game itself it's the game but
just the feel of the game is regular
Xbox still just the trash that I heard
about yes yeah regular ex yeah it's it's
a little rough but I mean
shout-out to um a lot of people I know
I'm gonna get lost in cuz he's using his
music as well but I've heard that the
improvements have been tremendous since
I'm saying but again I did hear
obviously it's the loss so I'm on the
ass I'm on I'm sorry I mean to put you
out there but I did I did play it on the
original and it was choppy and it was
horrible when gunfights
I was clipping to [ __ ] and it was bad
way better than the updates they've been
doing has been fixing a lot of the
problems well go yeah updates are good
but it's all just like you know they
wanted this out before the holidays so I
mean when you played the game first on
your ass before the patches came out and
you spent 30 duck 30 bucks and you log
in you're like is this really what I got
I mean is there is there any pull back
to say it's like on PC the thing had
been going for nine months
and I was honestly I it's not a perfect
game on PC by any means but when you're
gonna send it out onto a console which
is basically a verified market of this
as games are supposed to run on console
they don't typically release broken
stuff okay let me retract that that's a
dumb state but they do no no but I mean
to the level of like this is almost Mass
Effect broken level to a point of map
loading frame rates and things like that
when you're gonna release a game and
somebody picks this up for the first
time and they're like yeah they got
their money but do you think it's fair
to the consumer to release a game even
if they're you know they know their
stuff coming out later
is that fair when they know it's still
it's early yeah but it's pretty trashy
early from when it gained early access
topic I'm willing to debate you in this
because when you're going through the
checkpoints to the game I don't know if
you play the game on xbox yeah yeah as
you're going through checkpoints to the
game to load in the game and all that
other stuff they're giving you a warning
this game is in beta this game is in
beta this point yeah if you purchase it
you can return it if you digitally
purchase you can call Microsoft and say
this game was broken I don't like it you
can return it oh that's an option yeah
that takes Microsoft you can do that
with all Microsoft games you can return
them especially digital games that is
the best thing Microsoft is great at
that they will delete that joint right
off of your hard drive
and your money will be right back in the
account did they do it with no problem
my thing is yeah guys sorry I was gonna
say it's like overall for the game
getting out to more people
absolutely okay it's a pub gee
especially if they can refine it to
where it's playable even if the
resolutions not that great right it's a
unique animal out there and the more
people can get their hands on it and the
more people that you can try and
describe like trying to put pubs you
know words to somebody's alright yes it
is hard to put in the word you know like
just a five minute video what is this
game I'm like it's really hard to put
into words let me show you it's like you
could spend 10 minutes looting get shot
in the back of the head and you're like
me and you don't want to do it again and
I don't know why honestly like that's
cool I just hope it you know they kind
of pick up some of the stuff so Xbox
just I feel like as broken as some of it
was before the rep like the og systems
of ps4 and Xbox they're not built to
really handle what it's trying to do I
don't know if they're ever gonna be at
the level of somebody would get to
experience if they sat down on my PC in
the other room and they'd be like this
is a different game like I mean the more
people that get this yeah absolutely
Lord actually sinister I want to just
jump
oh it's back yeah he's back okay Maddy
can hear us so he had a big update tpc
yeah he still he still may be going
through the update process Oh sinister
what do you feel the success of pub G
and it's been a great successes you know
that and for tonight I play them both
and I love them both they both great if
you gotta put it into short words it's a
Loutre shooter survival that's what it
is
yeah and technically you won't even get
shot in the back of the head we could
just I could just you know knock you out
with a pan oh my god
if little shooters kill first time we
played you know he ran up on me and shot
me and I shot me and shoot me and I
wasn't gonna turn around and shoot back
one of them dudes in the hood run up on
you or say you don't shoot any gangster
that's that's trolling big bad John you
gonna told everybody last week but you
did I'm totally getting the bathtub ami
told everybody get in a house this is
red spot this is the first time he's
playing so you know what's going on I'm
like in the bathroom if you wanna
survive Billy on Xbox the success feel I
just want to know like how many times
did I say I told you it's not gonna be
you have had your chest out from day one
what pub gee as far as it being a
success
far as it being Xbox being home for
shooter inside people online at Xbox in
the comment section call me a corporate
slave because just because you predicted
it would be successful no just because I
tell people you know uh Lord addict on
here and gaming addict on there yes so
like I was just like look like like
people could sit there they can try to
say that I'm like you know I'm making
categories for Xbox gamers but at the
end of the day what is the one thing
that Xbox keeps trying to do this Jinbo
fell out mm-hmm
make it single player games what's the
one things that they have done that
sewed well the multiplayer games like
backed up I mean you have talked at
nauseam when we heard about pub G and
how it's perfect for the ecosystem
you know the multiplayer just it just
screams an Xbox game any game Microsoft
needs the purchase is this business one
yeah we did say that no doubt you've
been sticking to your guns good to see
your rewards paying off let's get Lord
Sovereign Lord King finish this thing up
with pub G success it's not surprising
it's not surprising at all like you know
the moment that game sold a million
copies in you know 48 hours
that's well you know this was gonna
happen I knew the playerbase is gonna
continue to rise they've had five
updates the game came out five updates
already in the game honestly once you
get still choppy in the lobby area still
choppy jumping out of the plane but once
you hit the ground the game's fairly
smooth like and that's and that's where
they're you know that's where the
money's made right there and the game
the game is is is is very close to what
you were you playing on PC same for the
60 frames per second stuff so again the
fun of the game even day one was still
there and I said that when we first
talked about I said guys have been
playing on the PC I get it we get it we
understand why this game has been such a
phenomenon and that s still translated
to the to the to the Xbox one so mm-hm
it's not surprising and I see that
number just continue to go up about
looking up G success
I'm just loving it I take it as small
doses because the level of frustration
and angst that you have in that game is
enough to stop your heart it's insane
the level of anxiety you feel see I was
playing a solo mission yesterday by
myself no actually it was this morning
when I came um I said let me jump on
real quick let me see no there's a
try-hard xenon yet good morning I'm
parachuting down into the facility I
went to the school I look over the most
horrifying feeling that you can see is
somebody parachuting which yes you know
the funny so I said to myself I said
well I gotta fight this dude I know I'm
gonna fight him I gotta fight him right
so I have all shout out the Plantronics
with Dolby Atmos 800 rigs that I'm
wearing ridiculous amounts of brother I
hit him up in the bathroom to the right
messin with the door handle okay thank
God my chicken I was I was at the very
top stairs in the apartment complex you
gotta keep in mind it's like six floors
up and I was at the adjacent angle of
the staircase and I was crouched because
like five people went in there at me
because I was the only one alive how
about I heard where they weren't all out
sides in that room but I was sitting
there with that shotgun port of that
door I heard word direction they're
coming from I heard that like two or
three were a couple floors below be
heard one person was the floor right
below me and one was in the hallway to
the lesson shoutout to dolby atmos
indeed cuz my wife was watching me and
she saw me just open a door and shoot
out of a bush she was playing on the
sound bar where the surround system
you're doing yourself a disservice this
game needs to be played with the
headphones on mm-hmm all right you need
to be in isolation type of situation so
you can hear everything like you get
people creeping up behind you in the
grass yes you need this this level of
immersion in this game because it's
necessary to survive if somebody tells
you that you will have super hearing in
the world of survival you will take it
right so trust me when I'm telling you
if you had a bad experience with the
game try it again with headphones on I
want to ex not a regular system second
floor story building once and he was in
the back behind these books this son
just like bookshelf they don't see
they're like okay he's right beside he's
in the hallway if I don't hear this he's
like he's gonna trust me don't down the
room jump in the tub John shout out the
love a fair job of it would you know
what's funny boss is actually made a
good points like when John Jack actually
jumped in a chat we would out trying to
explain to him why pub G is so crazy he
didn't have to give us a hard sell it
was an easy sale it was a horse I said
look we will launch this game it's gonna
probably look like the worst game you've
ever seen
I said feeling like a ps2 slash ps3 game
but about I said John when I tell you
right now he's the most fun this most
addicting game I've played in a long
time so we squatted up parachute it down
and immediately across like a bank a
riverbed we see like four people in a
shootout I'm like don't get down it's
crazy I said we came out over - we gotta
get weapons we just got pistols let
double go you know so we're sitting
there with Louise he here John's
excitement like ooh I love this game
this game is crazy I need to show you
guys something
John Cody's would have a screen shot
hold you trying to put clothes out -
Cody's definitely Weston talked about
this you want to put you out there let
me know what you ready - busy
sponge worthy till he sees you the
sponge go I'm sorry
anyway King December let's go all right
so all right some people in this room so
something about my good friend Aaron
Burr I like to thank you for putting it
out there what went down with MPD's um
for his tweet was beautiful
well it's kind of poetic it was nice he
didn't go at Nintendo this allows me to
believe that Nintendo and Microsoft was
working on their chat this is me leads
out of that religion because you know
why he said 8th gen so it wasn't
anything disparaging pointed towards the
switch he said that you know Microsoft
came in the highest MPC MPD's of
December ever and it out the the
PlayStation 4 as switch 1 December
alright in the console of being sold in
North America this lends credence to my
conspiracy theory on PlayStation Lion
well November the reason why I say that
PlayStation and sony has fudged the
numbers in November is because
when you lose November it seems like
you're losing that may turn the tide
then may people make people say yes they
know no no I'm gonna win a chain let me
get on this winning train right over
here because you know Microsoft might be
you know doing this or switch might be
doing this if switch has won every month
since they came out they lost November
why is that that's kind of weird right
but they win December Microsoft it goes
back into your theory because you say
because uh this is like this is how it
should have been all along
I'm just saying something looks kind of
stink but clean though every clock every
month then all of a sudden the most
important quality I got air quotes going
up guys the most important month where
the world is watching you pull out a
victory and then you go right back to
losing you know they should have been
smart they should have won on October
and November and then just eat that
December and then go back to loser for
the rest of year but no it's a no smalls
months and then win November and then
lose December Lord addict as our second
member of the we're down both of us
sinners to the left and our down and
join the table killed all day digital
egg Cody stored back to back in the
house to the right ah I see I see I see
you got big major big shout out to the
RDX me that's what's up they were ILP
and on the exit of our little game
together see that's what I want
I also really want you know these guys
to be able to have 100 main servers
where we can pick who we want from my
entire friendless let's go let's get
this thing popping right if that's the
partnership with Microsoft that to me
will make pub G like really great back
on track with the the other subject
timeout real quick did anybody else
other than myself get the pub G survey
from Microsoft I did not
what answer everything about the game
they asked me everything from how do I
like certain aspects of the game they
asked me what did I think about the
graphics was the game worth the purchase
what didn't I like about the game was
the game too hard was it this was it
that I told them the input lag was the
the biggest problem that I was having
with certain things I trust me I
honestly believe that their on position
to purchase this game and not let this
game get to PlayStation and any foreign
fashion it would be a big game for them
to really secure it no it was sinister
what do we feel about the NPD results so
it looks like our Xbox one out so ps4 in
the similar but switch out sold all over
all over all units so what do you feel
is out there you I know I know
switch was doing good you know a switch
gang everybody's playing I love what
they're doing with the you know they're
trying to go along the Xbox ways and
bring some of the older games for the
Wii U up to date so it's it's sort of
the same path of light by game pass but
they're trying to sell each game
individual whatever they're getting
there your opinions on the December NPD
leaked reference to switch probably
winning and which call xbox outselling
PlayStation 4 from month December switch
to kind of make a rebound and come back
I mean a lot of those uh you know those
lot of switches under the Christmas tree
you know so that I expected a lot of
that
for Microsoft I think it's good I think
it's a it's good to go into January with
some momentum just have these numbers
under their belt saying that they're
selling well that the ex is selling well
and to me what it SiC signals is that
they need to start talking about more
clearly what's coming like you already
had intended with the direct
Sony's already put out there you know
what they need to start talking about
stuff beyond sea of thieves everybody's
eyes I got into the sea of thieves you
know the clothes made of thing the
clothes made a thing yet with the
pre-order and whatnot so I'll be playing
that I guess within the next couple of
weeks
um but yeah they need to start they need
to start talking about what's coming get
people excited so I definitely agree
lordy pontus what do you feel about
these NPD numbers uh I mean honestly
happy for him like in the grand scheme
of like I mean for one for the switch
it's awesome well yeah it has been a
awesome console to see do what nobody
thought it would do and just the fact
that it's done that and honestly hey if
Xbox one it is there like a
are you wondering if it's real or not or
it's just more the fact that they know
it isn't it well well looking as his
theory about I was like that was what I
don't believe so these numbers in
November that's that's my position on it
we don't how you you would let mean yeah
it's like for sales a the more is out
there and honestly if Xbox gets a little
closer to PlayStation anyway hopefully
that just push this PlayStation a little
bit more and they both push each other
like the more competition in the market
especially with Nintendo now being that
outside force are always kind of the you
know the odd egg in the basket but you
got a look at him because they're always
doing something that a fair amount of
people want to look at so yeah is like
more the merrier and all this and I'm
happy to see Nintendo successful so
absolutely absolutely I mean I thought
the numbers came out and I'll shout out
to the brat podcast and uh Matt biscuit
telling those guys you know they put
that out there early a little early and
I actually I agree punk was the one
put it out early in response to a boil
put a rack that's the good early on but
um yeah he just you know let him nobody
was honest and that switch did winning
this is good for the industry I think
this is good I want to shout out MLG
Mike Mullis our models because I'm he
made a tweet actually retweeted it and
it's kind of interesting for Xbox to win
that because um I mean over PlayStation
and since that it coincides what game
released that month
it's babji so we it has to be a
correlation and hopefully you know
Microsoft can really start paying
attention to that and again and a lot of
people feel like exclusives don't matter
but at the end of the day it's one of
those things where just like look you
know we cannot deny the effect of jihad
on Xbox one XK one today when did they
start on bundling it with the system it
was you know what's funny I remember it
was like December 17 they're like the
20-something because marks move my
cousin he spots one X right there and he
got pumped you for free ok yeah so it
makes sense I mean people it's one of
those things that you got a little bit
like this is a early access game that
move consoles like move consoles on his
own in addition to getting packed in at
you know at the midway point of the of
the month it's yeah it's one of those
things like they need to really
understand the impact of this game and
hopefully like we've been saying like if
they're in a position that's picked this
up and keep it in-house they need to
keep that 3 milli and it's not even yeah
I mean we got a full month from release
like that's insane yeah look how
successfully so yeah it's interested so
we are going to move on unless any of
the laws anything left to say on the NPD
Louis sovereign there was a mini from
Nintendo that's ago there goes Kearney
no messing up names again
[Laughter]
they messed with an old Lord oh that's
right and try but yeah there was a lot
of speculation about what was gonna
happen in the day in January people were
talking about this and a being the rag
was knotted right Nintendo was mom the
whole time and on the 11th this past
Thursday they dropped a direct mini and
that's exactly what it was a 14 minute
quick rundown of probably what we can
expect in the first quarter right some
of the stuff we can expect in the first
quarter of this year
so let's just run down what would they
brought out they brought out some Wii U
games that we knew were probably coming
anything that wasn't as successful as
they would have liked on the Wii U is
coming to the switch that's a guarantee
you know as a guarantee so we have
Donkey Kong Country tropical freeze
coming it's been a person of that game
coming to the switch and that's
fantastic because I had had kind of
given up on my switch by that time I did
not play so and it's phenomenal and I'll
be buying it again on switch is that the
one where they got the little with the
cool one with the box yeah he's on a
surfboard
yes tweet that and put the drug being on
the game was funny yeah that's awesome
it only sold worldwide something like
maybe one and a half million copies so
so you're looking at minimum another
half million copies on switch if not
much more it's gonna be conservative I'm
being concerned
let's go so - same thing Hyrule warriors
I warriors was on we you and I believe
they had a variety of everyone can down
to Earth's formula yeah that's huge out
there trust me I can't stand them games
either but well I wanted it all switch
anyway so I'm happy to toilet it's huge
man for suddenly that game continued and
we're getting more breath of the wild
themed stuff for that solo I mean they
giving you the game they're improving
upon and then they're giving you more
stuff it's a kind of you know they they
leans into what what the switch has been
up until this point giving you breath
little lost off so again it's if you
haven't played the game you never picked
it up it's fantastic to have it on the
go now
right so let's see in terms of in terms
of palm now we're getting the world ends
with you is it ten year old 3ds game a
DS game actually that's it's a
square-enix RPG it's kind of rhythm
based in terms of the combat it was kind
of quirky but it I mean it was very well
received and that's another game that in
I think total might have sold maybe
close to million copies as ten years ago
this is the game again you put it out on
a switch you have over 10 million
switches out in the wild now it's gonna
sell it's gonna so I don't think they
give me bravery default one and two well
I guarantee you were product some point
we're gonna see the bravely default
series on there we're probably gonna see
the latest Metroid on there we're gonna
see a link between worlds on there it's
not it's all coming and I'm happy for it
I'm bring it all bring it all give me
everything everything but Virtual
Console
don't say that don't say for some reason
I don't see you thanks to 20 worlds what
else will be getting ok so and then
we're getting the new East game the East
game that came out last year on the s4
and it came out on Vita and it came out
it's finally coming to the switch again
a lot of people
I feel awful playing them playing my
Vita Vita was a fantastic little console
these are the type of games I don't
really want to play on my big console
hey they'll probably fall to the wayside
so having it on something on the switch
it's gonna get to play that it deserves
so he's an Indies baby how much what
yeah then this is where they belong to
me alright so we have that we have some
DLC coming for a Mario ravager finding
getting don't you call me Mario rabbit
is that paid Lord thoughts or is that or
is that I believe there is some pack
there is some sort of premium pack if I
have to place it down to cone I'm buying
a mum buying him straight out yes and we
know you can get the amiibo to if they
have amiibos that work for them
have you seen the amoebans for no no one
for Mario rabbits I'm kind of mad
because the whole marketability of the
the rabbit will lend to more me Bo's
disgusted learn annex face may be
smiling level pissed blood addict off a
little bit more but you notice his
sickness has allowed him confused on
that stuff we're getting some a new
character for pokken tournament if you
pick that up again
pokken tournament was the game didn't
necessarily appeal to me but I played it
at e3 and it was very cool game I'm not
quite sure how well it did on the Wii U
but again it can't hurt porting it to
the you know having imported it to the
to switch and now getting more
characters and what motes in the the
definitive corner Mario Party yeah they
need one yet they absolutely they
announced the tennis friend oh this is
the thing okay so let's get into the new
stuff and we'll finish off wait with
Dark Souls and to the new stuff that's
been at nasse okay so we got a date for
Kirby Star allies um and that again
Kirby's always been had it more of a
younger lean to it but I think like I
talked about there's a lot of switches
on the Christmas trees this year so now
though it's more than just a hardcore
who purchased in March now we have the
kids really on this system now so you
need to put games out they kind of draw
them in they gave you the Dragon Quest
builder's demo which is basically
Minecraft in Dragon Quest world and it
works it works it is a fantastic type of
that game so that's gonna be big for
them Kirby so our allies is gonna be big
for them with the younger audience was
yet Mario Tennis is another game again
with Mario Tennis it's a brand new Mario
Tennis
Frances always liked a song I don't care
about Mario Tennis where's Mario Golf so
bubbly back yeah we don't like yoga you
love golf
after playing a marrow golf game and the
same I just like it had a story mole he
looked very intuitive like a head like
it wasn't just vs. like when is dad
coming out yes I'm looking forward to
that tennis that would be the first kind
of single-player story mode in and mario
tennis game since like mario advance
tennis advance like the game would match
so it's been a long time and people have
been asking for it so it's good that
we're finally getting something a deeper
auto Jota Jota I got to interrupt you
there on quote people who's been asking
for who's have been asking for Mario I'm
missing the tennis in the face at the TV
okay for me this year officially retired
that they're gonna stop going up my boy
yeah I don't like
we gotta break 20:17 back with the beef
tag team so yeah so we're getting that
um they have a new SNK fighting game
with just the women from the SNK like I
was talking about like a lot of children
and younger people finally getting
switches the game itself can brings in
and so it's obviously gonna appeal to
girls the young girls in terms of the
way it plays it's not like a difficult
fighting game like it's one of those
when I first saw it I was disgusted but
then thinking about it I said yeah I
mean it's it's got to do it's it's it's
not talking to us it's talking a
different section of the week I don't
know where Jane was talking to but I
want to see how it's those cuz it might
be interesting like who picks up this
game like really like young girls
even just younger boys like so what
you're trying to say that young girls
can have complicated or fighting control
that they can't not that they can't or
they would not like to play those games
but some don't some dumb you know
disgusted me I was like you know what
SNK games or some of the games are like
lady lady [ __ ] Bob was asking K
heroines tag-team frenzy looks like a
Final Fantasy East refried a second
mashup it's a mash-up and then it says
and after you die your hip points ain't
the only thing that could save you like
after they take away your hip points
there's other things that you could do
that continue to fight I said wow they
really dumb in the game down from women
trying to act like women can't play
second or
gamer we'll see how it does
alright so now in the Indy front of the
Indy front we're getting Vayne and we're
getting Celeste today's dirt yeah phase
one of those incubator games from EA of
the EA originals the same thing they
brought up or is it yarny so it's it
looks fantastic and again it's a game
that on my console home console that
probably is not getting a burn that it
should so I'm picking it up on the
switch it's an action-adventure game
team sounded like a platformer same with
Celeste Celeste seems like it's more in
the old-school vein it it seems like
this is a mechanic where you stick to
the walls and slide down the walls and
stuff like that so again it's a game
that's perfect
what you call it uh quinion you say if a
baby by Zonk he's waiting for flippin
death yeah okay continue that's
absolutely what it is like in the in the
meat boy vein that's and then we
finished off with the big one we're
getting dark souls on on remastered
version that's good
listen I I didn't play any original Dark
Souls on 360 when it first came out and
I think I talked about this way back
when I said ah at the point I was in my
life I don't think I had the patience to
really want to play that game so I
immediately sort of discarded
disregarded it I'm not gonna be able to
get into this game and then once it came
to bat compact I said you know what let
me try this out and I sat there and I
played good six seven hours of it um
same thing with blood-borne I got into
blood-borne and it's one of those things
that if you're able to get past the you
know the frustration of getting your
ass kicked over and over again it clicks
for you it clicks for you or you're like
now I don't want to do this anymore and
I'm done and it clicked for me um but
again there was so much other stuff
coming out that I just fell off of it
again switch is the perfect platform for
me to play this game to completely
finally heart right they're all trash
where is smash brother there's a lot of
hate on the internet about the contents
of this many people it's a mini it was
14 minutes long and now historically
they've definitely followed the mini up
with a full on direct a few egos yes why
don't you said let me jump in real quick
song because this was big on reddit this
was like trending so if you take away
the greater score each direct mini has
always followed a standard direct within
20 days so if that's the case in that
follow suit and that listen regardless
how people feel about the games that
meeting was packed right so if that
means they have so much to show that
they gave them their own segment and now
another directors coming with another
all-star game to me that's really
promising y'all but I don't understand
the hey like people talking about oh
it's there you know it's the new um
remaster council yes it is give it to me
give me give me all the remixes give me
all the porn that's it's it's a
different type of thing once you can
play Dark Souls at work on your lunch
break or something of that nature you
know that you don't have to be for that
I have to wait till I get home at 6
o'clock or whatever it is you know
whatever time you work from or listen I
got to go to this doctor's office let me
go get past this boss um Dark Souls you
have to really take your mind and change
it to this stuff is usually done when
you need free time when you need to
occupy some time for something right so
if you
taking the kids to the doctor's office
oh whatever it is that you're doing
during your day you have a moment of
alone hop out I see your tweets and when
you playing that game I know when you're
playing against oh I don't really get
that time with my switch yeah you know
my switches is never coming off the dock
only time I switch goes out is like when
I go to Cali or when I go on trips oh I
know that you travel a lot for work or
stuff but oh yeah I'm surprised that you
don't use your switch in a mobile
function but with as much driving and
going all the places you do Oh Steve see
the thing with my thing is when I go to
handle my business um there's no free
time handling face-on right so I'm like
you know real quick I'm only now
probably like two hours three hours tops
just here you know yeah and then I get
back home and I'm like oh let me put
this on but then you know I get somebody
like Lord Krishna hit me up like a lord
Chris always hit me up yeah let's do
this pop G or somebody hit me up for
this destiny or something like that so
my time unless I'm going on it's a lot
of sense though because now I understand
like the way I look at his always being
like a portable console for me cuz it's
like if I'm home I'm not gonna choose to
switch over so that's why it has that
that special thing for me but likely you
know lost our sayings like if I'm at the
doctor's office or you know whatever you
know that any term but I look forward to
long waiting periods now I'm about to
buy a system for my son because the
games on it you know he he likes to play
his game for anyway
and I think he's mature enough even
though he
the seven years old son in the next
couple of days he's mature enough to not
destroy the system yeah so I don't fear
that you know and the games that was
that was shown were very nice game so if
people had a problem with the direct he
just probably had a problem with the
content of the director and they wanted
newer games let's get a lord violence
loss office finish I want to get a lot
of artists in on his opinion of the mini
Marxist I know your switch game so what
did you feel when you saw the mini the
director came I mean not a lot of them
do a lot for me and I was like Hyrule
warriors has never really really been my
thing
II need Mario sports day in-game though
I'm definitely always don't read a golf
via tendency like mega man soccer on
Mikado I don't know if that was Super
Nintendo that cracker goofy and the fact
that they're gonna put a story mode in
there where you're fighting a giant
piranha plan or whatever it is
sign me up and that things like smacking
the ball back at me and whatever it is
like that's just gonna be goofy fun so
as he said perfect thing like what did I
do with my Mario one Christmas break I
took it up to my in-laws house and I'm
just sitting there I'm like past five
hundred moons and it's yeah I was like I
mean that's perfect so the balloon thing
for Mario the Luigi thing of course
Luigi is kind of get in the you know
backend of everything always but you sad
face for Luigi but I mean hey I'm gonna
sleep that's more just the idea like
they continue to support these games in
splatoon
be it Mario Odyssey which usually is
typically gonna be a complete package
they're adding something to a Mario game
like that's kind of a sonic and it's
free yeah I was like Donkey Kong is
always cool original Donkey Kong Country
super nintendo made me want to pull my
hair out it was also remember Mega Man 3
is one of my favorite games and that
will make you want to kill yourself so
now there's so much easier with the
savestates like no I mean my only thing
about Dark Souls I want to play it
because I love blood-borne in Dark Souls
3 yeah
from what I've heard is they have
refined that combat and made it faster
and more reactive if they don't make the
combat feel the way that newer ones do
and it's the kind of an old or clunky
feel I'm probably not gonna enjoy it
like I know looks like you got to learn
the game for what it is but I like the
challenge of Dark Souls I like the
challenge of narsil 3 and the challenge
of blood-borne because if I lose I feel
like it's on me cuz I didn't dodge
faster but yeah gotcha yeah I'm curious
when they remaster it if they like kind
of give it a modern update for the feel
like if its back to the bosses and like
you know going back to the story for one
but with newer feel perfect sign me up
they made it clear that it was not
because there was speculation it was
gonna be remade in the Dark Souls 3
engine and they made a clue that that
wasn't it so I don't know if they could
still make some bat I know it's gonna be
on console it's gonna be so that's this
premium just the power point so you beat
the chappie 30 frames per second version
of it right I mean like six years ago
yeah so so why would I buy make if it's
the same game pretty much then if it's
the same thing I played six years ago
No you guys act like there's no logic
behind that you don't need to sovereign
making it to the show I've been waiting
for the real sovereign to show up to the
party young brothers do not know him
like I know him okay
Suzi Azzam and the UFC in the beginning
this is just the tip of the iceberg of
my brother here an addict to me this is
my issue with fanboy ism because I know
addict is a boy necessarily there's an
issue with me saying if I was gonna buy
it would be on a system that it's not
running it and like it ran six years ago
that's because because it's your fact is
your reality you know your that's my
facts that's the fact that the developer
themselves brought out about the fact
that you're putting down anybody who's
gonna pick it up now not this kind of
kind of low-key reply it like why would
anybody pick that up what he was
implying was why would anybody pick it
up in the only thing you do
it's like why like I don't understand
how people keep justifying these it's
not about justifying but here's the
thing you understand like there's a
there's a huge audience from Nintendo
right like me I've never played a Dark
Souls game I've never played one right
so if I'm at home right but I play Dark
Souls on the Xbox one X absolutely right
but I'm on the goal that's what the
switch provides me I'm at work at a desk
in reference to ye boots with that it's
not about defending Nintendo there's a
bunch of people people forget Nintendo
has their own ecosystem they have
they're all people that all they play is
Nintendo games they don't have a song
you don't play all that other stuff so
when you throw this title to them
there's millions of people who this is a
new title to them that it's like wow you
don't say they never know about that
that's all we try are you are you pissed
off at the fact that there's even a
remastered like you're pissed off at
that
I'm not even debating on this
conversation you got three words in my
mouth know what he said was he wasn't
pissed off with that but he said was is
your individual with choice and the
choice is 60 frames over 30 frames you
know basically that were basically we're
way and then it just went left position
like Lord Alec is saying look for me I'm
not buying it I get that I totally
understand he played Dark Souls years
ago he played doom he's not gonna buy
but if he would buy superior version
right and don't get me wrong either I
don't want in the gate Lord attics point
there are a lot of people who feel that
way they have the next thing that's Lady
right 30 frames per second doom or no so
I completely understand that crowd but
there is the crowd are obviously like
windows
don't have or just like he wanted said
we just care about portability so it's
like yo I'll take a little sacrifice
just like keep playing you know I mean I
cuz I'm not do this buying both of them
both I want that one on the console
there's 60 frames 4k I want that one and
I wanted on the go to and I'm just gonna
I'm gonna be that dumbass who does this
I gotta defend Lord addict know it
disrespect and I feel you loss uh
because you're a special person if I
have like nice way of saying a lot of
other things and we know Wolfenstein 2
is coming to the switch I can't I can't
do it I can't but I'm not gonna sit here
and argue with you then no you can't
that's never been my argument my
argument is I'm not gonna sit here and
shoot that version down without having
played it and if that means me
purchasing it I'm gonna do that
I won't you know what I would like for
them to do because I really want them to
get this ecosystem with Microsoft going
that these games this let's say I'm
playing it at home with my whatever come
on I'm playing it on my switch or
whatever and the same save points can
travel as much between the system I
think it's gonna happen I don't know
angry birds tweet was more telling than
y'all think listen Lord King now be my
dream if there was somehow like you
could cross save nobody's talked about
this in as many and this directors
coming but if in this director shows up
that because you know the directors
coming we got what 19 days 17 days
coming if they don't talk about the
ecosystem when it comes to the online
that they promise that
coming out in a beta form of this year
if they don't talk about it then that
means is something more powerful to that
you know and what a way to make a super
splash at e3 run away to challenge the
naysayers and show you because if
Nintendo said we're gonna allow cross
play with Microsoft in these games that
means that they're playing friendly with
this companies hey I take it cuz that
would mean the intent of is Xbox get a
meditator get something good out of an
infrastructure pushing these dinosaurs
out attic
these dinah solution these dinosaurs out
and if they take these old people out
the pass just every switch to the point
I really do believe that they would
treat these older people with respect
and put them down this mini was not for
me
but I will say they with titles that I
thought with new games and I came to
find out were we you ports so um you
know hey I was like I'd never seen it
before that's pretty good to know and
it's the low key for me on the actual
payday getting a release date because
that kind of went under the radar and I
know me and Mark I was talking about
that you know just worried if they would
actually have an online infrastructure
it does and confirmed so I got my eye on
little bit of payday 2 action and Dark
Souls I mean yeah pretty huge huge game
you know very impressive that it was
announced on the switch stage and yeah I
mean I'm pretty pretty excited about
that so if anybody got anything else
before we move on Lawson you had
anything to say about the mini director
you'd be so that is opening the door for
finally even if they're third even if
they're last generation it's just the
fact that those have touched a Nintendo
platform now is opening the door for
people to realize Nintendo was opening
their mind from a narrow narrow narrow
road just thinking about more stuff so
it's like that just those pieces good
shout out the lord chief time to chat he
said i would say these bugs ago then
tell is evolving i can't call him
grandpa anymore i can still call him
grandpa when they got that phone and
string contraption of online off the
hook yet Lord Chief down to Lodi bounces
point these are all good signs we want
their party's opponent we complain that
they don't have third-party support the
fact that these games are touching
Nintendo consoles is is tremendous so we
gonna move on we got the last subject
the big one we're gonna close this thing
out the destiny to development update
world has awaited this day was January
11 Christopher Barrett's tweet bungees
tweet Twitter was going crazy
Oh everybody's pressing f5 refreshing
the future of definitely two hinges or
what they were gonna say and boy we got
a lot to say so real quick um you know
they want to come out within normal
statement you know we're not just
listening we're doing ready monsters
they they're very passionate about that
subject and it's just a bunch of stuff
so the first thing they touched on
briefly was um just in terms of what's
free it post-loss launch content and
what's not so you know with expansions
that's content that is purchased like
Kercheval cyrus all that stuff you know
that stuff comes with an array layer
which is a lord addicts favorite word Oh
muki really strikes new destination you
know crucible maps so on and so forth
now seasons which would be considered
like iron banner faction rally all that
stuff that's gonna be free to all
players down so I thought that was
pretty huge they talked about ever verse
they came very clean to the fact that
ever verse was too far and Tessa's um
favor they felt there was a lot of
activity rewards that were kind of
hidden behind the bright engrams also
bright engrams if you notice when you
played the dawning like the bonds you
remember when you played you leveled up
you would just get a standard Engram you
wouldn't get the dawning Engram so now
they've made that change that's gonna
have a direct purchase options they're
gonna revamp ever verse they're talking
about crimson days coming up they're
bringing back shout the Lord SWAT that's
my crimson days buddy
I'm sorry pan you gotta let him go for
that that Valentine's weekend we get our
duel along but of their brain cream days
back and they're gonna have a legendary
weapons a whole bunch of things they
couldn't have a whole bunch of new
milestones associated with it crimson
engrams will be on also you can get that
the standard way not just through the
ever first or so a lot of that stuff you
know I talked about exp rates they
claimed investigating you know there was
a big controversy with the XP throttling
you know they got their hands slapped
because of that but right now they do
agree it's too slow in general and
lopsided toward specific activities so
they're gonna go in today and look at um
trying to evaluate how they can make
that better that's still ongoing and
then it came up with the roadmap so they
started talking about January 30th so
we're getting masterwork armor January
30th and I'm like yeah I'm very happy
I'm a huge fan of masterwork shouting
look how about - that's what got me
playing curse words in the harbor right
now there's gonna be some stats that
it'll be reroll abou and actually some
things that you're going to be able to
adjust so for right now it looks like it
just increased in while you're using
your super so that's the first one now
they're talking about a raid reward we
work this is you they get ya
January 30 if they're talking about raid
specific armor
perps drop in you know the rate vendor
will also directly sell Leviathan and
eater of worlds armored with the
purchase of raid tokens and legendary
shards they adding a new ghost that drop
in the Leviathan and either world raid
encounters um that's gonna be raised
specific they attend on creating much
more raid and activity unique rewards in
the future I thought again this is just
no speaking I was personally I think
that was huge this is something that
community has complained about February
update strike scoring this effect is
going to return so it's gonna come to
the nightfall and high score tracking
they're going to replace and get rid of
the timer and I know that was a
controversial subject because a lot of
people did not like the timer and I know
he bought this might be a little heavy
because he can go back to soloing night
falls again I haven't done him in a
while and it's like I was like hey but I
had to talk to people like esoteric if I
actually took the time to learn I hope I
could get there but for somebody like
him from what I've seen sorry to cut you
off before in there it looks like they
are going to be doing some pieces that
are gonna still allow people on his
level and looking at my crap together
back on his to challenge yourself still
they're just doing in a different way so
yeah absolutely I think that's huge in
it you know just bring him back strikes
calling in general that was a feature
from destiny one I love that feature you
get the rainbow you know you get all
those different little it promoted
competition and that was one of my
favorite features of destiny - I mean
that's the one that's coming back now
destiny to mods 2.0 they're gonna rework
the entire armor and mod system you know
they're gonna get rid of redundant mods
they can add stuff that's actually gonna
be more beneficial gameplay now on quit
playing crew mints PC improvements they
talked about Tex chat
yeah yada yada spring actually one more
which was big was the fire team members
on the destination map so when you load
in during the patrol you can see where
your guys are actually on the map yeah
that's huge like that you take three
other people in patrol executive exotic
repetition reduction you know we
everyone complained about getting the
damn same exotics I know
sinister goes crazy when he keeps
getting duplicates so I know he'll be
happy about that spring 2018 this is
another big one you know they're gonna
take a lot of feedback from the cursor
excited stuff cuz people mad this was
for me I never thought I'd see this
crucible 6v6
coming back to destiny that I would
never have thought was gonna come I'ma
be honest y'all coming too many people
is complaining about it
Lord addict was with me when I when I
talked with earth McGuirk they're at
home and destiny and I pressured him I'm
like man 66 no hope maybe even for Iron
Man and all he kept saying with the
company line we have nothing to report
at this time but now it's the time it's
6v6 they also adding crucible ranking so
there's gonna be two crucible statuses
when it's gonna be called valor which is
a progression rate that goes up as you
complete matches winning helps you move
up faster but there are no lost
penalties then they're gonna have this
thing called glory which is a
progression rank and it's almost like a
halo thing that goes up when you win and
down when you lose so I thought that was
pretty cool
private matches return is fringe but up
yet six weeks ago I took my mayhem will
return in limited events at season three
more fixes yadda yadda yadda
they're gonna talk about balance and
weapons updates we got to wait a little
bit for that you know same thing with
armor and balance weapon up passage so
that's gonna happen season reputation
improving the iron banner in faction
rallies on playlist reduction in the
crucible so they do all the most needed
shout the Lord carboxyl and Lord King
the multi emote wheel will come finally
you're the vault space they're adding
additional 50 slots to the vault they're
also gonna add on an exotic accessory
tab almost kind of like kiosk II kind of
stuff that destiny went had the kind of
just limit stuff from the vault for my
PC guy Shadow Lord suave doing tower
chat that's huge and then to end off the
update for 2018 these are the things
that they are working on but they're not
ready to discuss but they said it could
come in for 2018 or sooner so one is
going to be on item collections and
records now this one is key weapons
slot and archetype improvements that can
be taken many ways some people you know
fusions and shaadi side of the heavy
slot you know to make them a little bit
more viable since everybody's using
rocket launchers right now and the
colony the roaches right so definitely
get the send those roaches after them
basically useless nobody used it until
the colony so I thought it was a great
idea they put the colony in there and I
like the weapon additional crucible
playlists Rumble we're gonna have to
wait on Rumble till fall most likely
better clan wars they're gonna talk
about master work exotics I think that's
huge because master works are so good
right now I'm actually running with all
legendaries almost right now I really
know that me too that's how mass works
are so we got that we got trials at an
on improvements we got to wait a little
bit pinnacle weapon and gear shaders and
dismantling I don't know why it's gonna
take that long for us to not to be able
just mass delete shaders but another
thing would be cool what's up back
trials of Osiris oh please say I'm oh
you can you can uh you can much like the
same way you do a vendor's where you
leave yourself with one of them like the
only fights that you do on those
top-tier pvp's is trial zone nine versus
trials no stars hey I'm with it I'm with
me I don't like that one side chick I
want my I want my cyrus back on brother
Vance back in the leaf where he's
supposed to be out for Osiris a lot to
talk about
I got two of these guests on you know
respected in the destiny you need for
this purpose trying to be money in the
chat um here we go so let's start off
with Lord eat bonta's then we gonna get
sinister
My lordy bond is after this dev update
grab a cup of coffee coz grab a cut
let's get in time we waited to bring you
back for let's talk about how did you
feel
I saw your tweet prior to the update
telling everybody you know hold the line
yeah whatever I was sitting there
watching like people on Twitter like you
saw more consult it was like his
skeleton on the ground wait
for this and you could literally just
feel like attention on Twitter and
basically for anybody who's somewhat
active and destiny to be like there's
too much weight on whatever they good
they're gonna say that it's never gonna
be close now I'm not gonna apologize
about destiny too because there's a lot
of decisions that were made about
destiny too and I haven't done a lot of
videos about this yet that's why my one
about this is gonna be long wait for
crap that they left out of destiny too
though was in destiny and they took
three years to figure out I'm sure you
guys have already discussed all this oh
yeah all that stuff's line it's like and
I agree with all of that crap so they're
making steps in the right direction and
that whole article where it could have
been developed in 16 months and that
stuff comes out so there's a lot of
stuff that you're going on are they
listening the fact that you say okay
they're gonna clarify the conflict
they're gonna clarify the categories and
the first thing they talk about is ever
verse yeah that's a hot point that's the
first thing they put up there they
didn't try and stick it in the bottom
they literally put in the top and then
underneath that they said hey for
crimsoned days you're actually gonna be
able to earn an emote for doing the
nightfall earn a skin for doing the raid
and these are like cosmetics that you
can earn so their first steps are steps
in the right direction but there's so
many things that I want more out of in
all of this these are baby steps in all
of the right directions yes but there's
so much more that I think that can be
done a master work armor the idea behind
you know reducing incoming damage well
super effective okay but like yeah I was
like but I was like it could be cool for
mostly basically every arc super take
something like an arc Strider
stormcaller imagine imagine a striker
like like it depending on what kind of
you know throw show that increases on
your defense I wouldn't even use this
super I'll just I'll just go up to
people and shoulder bash yeah I mean
you'll just but it makes especially and
say the arc Strider it was probably a
big one it makes those more melee close
and personal supers more powerful and
more usable because if you're gonna be
too far away like a golden guns a Golden
Gun if I fire a celestial Nighthawk
that's not going to matter so it's
unfortunately on the other end doesn't
do as much for those so you've got
supers that don't get to take advantage
of it but there's certain ones that will
be more viable
if it stacks like 5 or 10% you know per
piece and it better stack her this is a
complete waste of time
just get aside but yeah some of them
it's like Golden Gun it's like fire done
John yeah there's no other than II for
that yeah I've heard you say but and
then the other side armor like and once
you guys may have seen kxs video and
we've all been thinking the same thing
armor is useless it doesn't mean slot
whether you find it from the legendary
or you find it from the raid if it's a
heavy titan armor it's all the same
stuff so one more stat piece for a
little more walking speed or a little
bit of that unfortunately for me they
need to rework all over so yeah I've
been over here like trippin like what is
that no signal about this as a jack I
mean the raid stuff that's all steps in
a great direction but it's like why did
you take it away destiny one felt solid
why did you I'll save my language mess
everything up yep
I was like cuz it's about to get a lot
uglier but knows like I was like so
putting stuff back in the encounters duh
I understand that we're going in the
right direction but when cogbi to read
that whole list all if I would have went
right after him and I bought this loot
this is literally the first sentence I
said oh so they're adding two things and
they're adding everything else I was a
destiny what I mean that's maybe why I
passed it but it was like I feel your
sentiments believe me addict I'm like
this stuff was there and we've all
wondered it's like why why why why don't
we go touch the Y I just want you to
listen I want to go to through everybody
on what was presented and what they feel
continue like strikes when coming back
gives a variety like you know time
limits not there
it lets me be more flex with a little
video so I was like it works out for me
but if somebody like esoterics like hey
let me crank everything on let me still
show you guys I'm a beast perfect so if
I honestly if it's flexible wear like a
gold medal is still something that
requires speed but you don't get the
gold but still finish
Paul two different sets of rewards that
actually could be a might actually work
like I mean I if you had three people in
a time tonight fall I still finished it
but I'd never hurt me in a group
nightfall so was a different animal but
in a group that was fine so but I had a
question for you with that with the sole
of the knife or have you finished the
prestige by yourself oh hell no I just
wanted to know because when I saw that
she was on today that was my biggest
question to you because I've been trying
to show you so low a time you've been my
high-water mark I was just like I gotta
talk to this dude to find out seriously
because I'm gonna be good you baby
that's putting me on pestle I don't
deserve on but thank you cynicism is
real easy gaminggod when it comes to
destiny one as well um Solo in a
nightfall is not something that you
can't do lightly to Yannick minimize
that all right though I'm telling you
okay some people can't get through it
with three people literally on my
channel was always like you solo it like
in your calm and clay I got called okay
here's a joke I got called the Bob Ross
of nightfall guides literally I'd be
like okay so you're talking to the boss
over here you're gonna have these guys
come out once he gets down to this
amount of damage do about 180,000 damage
and it was just very analytical but
that's my nature so I was like when they
kill him off I had that common once and
I about you know fell out of my chairs
your feelings all the rest of the I mean
they're talking about things we all want
mods they're basically their way for me
to see 335 but most of them are kind of
man unless I just want to throw all our
things on my Titan crucible rankings
it's a start but I'd love to see letters
private matches private matches to be
you're useless unless you just want to
host a tournament that's fine but I want
some games not private mean a different
animal fair enough so I would rather
have like you know you have snipers or
you have sidearms okay this is gonna be
funny no sinister shopping ID to beat
you up next I know I was like and then
just the highlights this one sentence
here is probably gonna sum up my
thoughts on this whole thing
exotic armor and weapon balance best
exotic weapons and armor are receiving a
comprehensive design pass to ensure they
stand out from the rest of the gear to
make sure exotic stand out from the rest
of the gear make it aesthetic exotic
exotic yeah so scared of braking balance
you could tell because when we had
exotics this year what was what was the
helmet of warlock helm that makes you
reach harsh speeds go up a little bit
that like dad exotics to fix to try to
make things speed up faster that's what
I knew I'm like the exotics were just
buffs like slight buffs to stuff as
opposed to truly feeling power or
garbage you can run with legendaries and
most people do because what's the point
I literally want something to wear like
if I'm wearing a chest for my Titan I
want a tough decision on anything exotic
be a weapon or armor I want something to
be like a god tier of all categories but
it's like if you're using the hand cane
and I'm using the rocket launcher they
both have their perks but I don't know
which one to pick because it actually
matters so I was like yeah fixing some
of this heading back to a lot of the
destiny one stuff I'm good with it
why on earth the vault I was like I'm
with destiny Gary on this one
twelve hundred and however many days on
the vault space like what the hell like
that can't be that hard
I'm not a broken but it's like it's just
it shouldn't be at least so no it's like
I'm a huge destiny fan I do a lot of it
it's what my channels on but my
frustration that's why I literally put a
poll on my channel it's like how long do
you guys want to see a video on this I
put five minutes ten minutes twenty
minutes does my first run-through on my
script was like 35 minutes long and it's
me venting basically it's like how much
do you want to hear and some people like
don't that just don't limit it just go
and also let's go alright it's gonna be
interesting so like heroic stir
when heroic strikes came in strikes have
no modifiers they're just drinks and you
have relic adventures that have new
modifiers WTF on my head going from
destiny 1 season 3 that were added there
were no reason it was all there already
so ready we have modifiers on nightfalls
just throw the same modifiers on heroic
strengths but they're not as hard but
you can have some fun and make them
random every time you go it there's yeah
so I will let other people talk as I
said you can hear me for a half an hour
there are things they are bringing I was
like for my summation there are things
that are bringing backs that are baby
steps in the right direction
there are band-aids to fix us there
stuff that should have been there from
lunch
so is it if it is it gonna be like
division one point eight two years from
now when we finally get taken king 2.0
maybe cuz right now it's kind of like
that's why there are other games out
there and that's why I was like if
you're not happy with this go play
another game because they may need some
time let me ask before I pass it off the
last question for you about this is is
it too little too late for a lot of
people probably is because be it the PC
players when you took away a prestige
raid when you add new content and if
they just got the they just got to play
destiny 2 for the first time they're
like I have a better gazillion other PC
games by so I mean that's it you got the
fortnight yeah you've got with a lot of
other stuff out there right now don't
take missteps on a completely new
consumer base that are that big like
they like there on the world of Reddit
and stuff even more than console peoples
are you guys maybe more of the exception
but the world of PC lives on that stuff
so they're more in the know so thanks ok
yeah so no it's like there's a lot to
the game that needs to reworked it's
baby steps but I was like and that's why
that's what I was gonna start my video
with it's like if you want this update
to change destiny from destiny this is
not the update for you this is not the
update you were looking for if you're
gonna first start where speak Lord
sinister I know right something bad baby
let's go
so for one yeah I know me as always even
when the numbers are down I'm sitting
here I was going to destiny with even
when people were not touching 3 million
went down I was the same lonely you got
lonely on destiny it really did and then
when you jump into trials and stuff
which is what you are about you are you
are a chair and now you only have the
sweats there's no more Regulus if you
only have the sweats rocking analog D
with the Antelope D and you know you
know a positive outlook positive outlook
colony these guys are just running
around 4.0 owing wrecking everything
you can't even help people get through
anymore because everybody's running
stack mm-hmm but let me ask a quick
question what sinister do you this is
another thing I'm seeing going out in
the community shout out to the five-team
chat my G and guys my friend Marabella
oh I got shot him out because I always
shot me out CJ Gibson and Destin Liguori
what people are saying is all this
sounds great with the crucible stuff but
people still upset that they gotta wait
so long for the meta change people
saying that the time to kill is way too
long and that like they they're not fast
enough with the balancing you know I'm
saying like you were complaining about
you know having are only a few weapons
to rock with and everybody's rocking the
same weapons again there's only a few
weapons with these arm
I like that do you know they're they put
in the little perks on the armor but I
know I think they're a little too late
they lost a large portion of the
community and large portion I'm ain't
coming back no matter what
destiny does unless they do something
taking key memory RAM and you as
to say this is not gonna happen it's
just too late and the community is hurt
it's hurt it's hurting that is this is
happen I got low sitting on my ass you
know with the updates she was there
anything that got you excited I said
okay this is what I'm talking about this
is what I like this like is this I did
like the master works I did like the
master works it gives you a reason to
keep going if you're still with the game
play like I said it's a little too late
some people even know about master works
they don't even know what that is and
they yes I'm done with the content in
the raid sucked and I'm done your clan
is up so um
overall your thoughts on this dev update
for you personally with this get you to
continue or you're like you know what
I've been playing destiny since day one
I'm gonna continue but they've they've
lost my hours if you can get what I mean
so there's no Louis bullying way more
than you know 80 hours a week let's do a
wave or than that and now it's dropped
to like four hours a week just in the
common stuff done and okay I'm on to pub
G I'm gonna go play for a night I'm
gonna go play you know some my solo
stuff but destiny used to have our heart
where we put more than 80 hours and your
wife is angry at you that feelings gone
and this comedies a full-time job in
itself it was such a selfish game it
wouldn't allow you to play on the games
because you had something to do every
single day depending on what community
and oakum preventing what goals you had
and to not have that isn't it weird I
like you but I gotta stop playing the
game now I feel like I'm not touching
backlog and I'm sitting on my I'm
sitting on the dashboard I'm like I'm
gonna go watch YouTube it's like what
happened we used to have people begging
to get in raising begging again in night
falls no one's there no cities in a
second you need a knife or I'll give you
a knife but I'm saying there used to be
a large community not just you guys
all the time put this nightcap you want
to sleep you fell asleep and we woke up
we were still here mm-hmm I saw the
information that was dropped out and I
got elated because crazy watch Lord to
flip on you see he's saying you up I'm
telling you now
what he did he just put a razor blade in
your apple let me explain the update
impressions it showed me that they're
listening it showed me that you know
there's an internal struggle with you
have bungee and you have Activision and
I I don't want to believe in my heart
that Bungie is what Activision is trying
to make them out to be because I believe
all those stuff was already available
for us to play in the same ways that
they were in destiny one when Activision
wanted to scale back you know for that
reason I know you want to touch that on
a little bit later and we're just gonna
talk about the topic enhance um my
impressions of it I'm happy I'm happy in
a stance that now I've been talking
about it for a couple of months since we
had masterwork armed guns when we're
gonna get the masterwork armors because
like everybody's been running around
with death they're perfect gun and he
made it masterwork you know um so I've
seen a lot of things like you know
people talk about you are used it um the
blue streak for masterworks because I
like the way this works so I used this
gun or this sidearm and I made it master
works and it makes you say to yourself
should I get this origin story master
works but should I make this nameless
midnight master when he leaves I have
over two thousand kills with my Betty
Devil's and a master works and it's it
is making it your own they're taking
their time out to fix it and make it
your own
I know some people have walked away from
it and they're not playing and that's
fine and you know you go over there and
you do that maybe I'm a fanatic maybe
I'm on our side of the page where no
matter what they do I'm gonna stay there
in hopes that they're gonna fix it
because such the good feelings that I
had from destiny one and in a feeling of
camaraderie with Sinister's taking us
through the the raid oh we're doing a
nightfall or we're fine glitter we're
doing this and those great moments are
still with me so even if I'm trudging
through the bad moments in the game
those good moments are still there I can
joke with sinister million days in one
but he can also say you'll remember that
time we have one shiny
Nighthawk or the war so we read it out
of there things that we can say that we
can't say for other games so live in the
café's we're doing with sinister and
addict just fight each other and just
you know try to get any with the dogs
and all that yeah it's it's it's the
point where we're getting there yeah
does it bother me in here cuz sinister
was the guy that was putting in 80 hours
a week and I can see him always on and
he'll jump in my party I jump in this
party what you doing we'll be going what
we doing with this mom but you know just
the same way that he's doing that I'm
staying doing this and I got a team that
we do this so it's never really changed
for me where it changed for him and and
and there's a lot of people that have
changed for but then there's a lot of
people that's like myself that it hasn't
changed for mmm cuz I seen you been
rocking hard since courser Osiris you
still bet you behind your promise never
stop even ever stop now here's the
question now what about we're gonna get
it to Attica I know he's got a lot to
say but what about like the raid lair
thing like I know and premise it was
great when they put it up on a board and
they were like yo and then we release
this you can do this and you can do that
but what would have been better is this
thing is a planet either different
planets within the world either yes
right it should have been right it had
been tied to Osiris a story like let it
go to mercury or something so that it
giving he's and after you beat the
campaign for Osiris that it's linked
now it doesn't feel there's that story
lake right there's this there's no link
to it it's like its own entity up in the
corner because it's always up in the
corner in the right and if you clicked
on it you clicked on it because you had
six people that want to do it and you
don't get the six people don't want to
do it because the perks aren't worth
that hmm speaking of which how did you
feel about there when it willingness in
I believe in on January 30th the raid
specific mods the race specific I'm
gonna get in there okay let's go I mean
give me I'm getting I'm getting it right
like soulless those souls the stuff
drops that allows us to get that stuff
listen I got attacked
I got sue I got all my I got my elite
squad that actually gets in there you
know I'll call Hawaiian I definitely can
call sinister you know you'll get off
there for tonight let's do it
how many do you have mm-hmm if I say I
got five and he's the six he's in there
if he here tummy we'll get the team
ready I'll be there whenever you get the
team ready so it's never been no I'm not
coming or whatever it'll stop whatever
he's doing if they if there's a group he
will show that he's it
he's it so I'm gonna get this over to
the Lord addict I know he's got a lot to
say it seems like he's learning about
these updates Lord Eric you still there
did you get my uh my the last one I'm
pretty much before the question for you
guys so I'll let you guys let's go no I
said on so I have to go next because I
mean oh no I can go now I can go
visiting I'm the way I'm with y'all
everything ya say I mean everybody make
great points bosses make great points
you know and I get it you know I think
it's one of those things that is like
the way I look at it is why did this
happen
it's like it's like a car accident
I'll try to make sense of it really why
did we get hit like yes I think we won't
ever be able to answer that because that
information won't come and I got a very
loaded box I'm about to break it right
now all right break it up break it up
all right
the way I see it is okay we had destined
gravity machines messed it up I think
rather the machines they had such a high
demand I don't think rats of the
machines was ever supposed to come out
well I think they're supposed to go from
right from that was made by the live
team because a lot of people to the left
at the last right shoulder they are
still incapable of producing content
frequent enough right now we were told
that with all these studios hi moon
studio what does it vicariously my
scooty is you know to help with the PC
port we were told you know that this was
the full team that's need to know yeah
absolutely absolutely because it's not
that they shouldn't have made the PC
port because let me tell you something
these PC crowd dudes they do not play
they are highly critical they were dead
very jaded they will turn on you in a
hot second all right if it's not right
they have millions of steam games to
play and they don't care about you they
will tear up your situation leave you
all messed up over there and the world
believing this is true only for the PC
guys is true but these console dudes now
we got to be stuck with this no they
should never put that game on PC but
there was Activision chasing those
dollars okay if they would've sorry go
ahead
so take all of the stuff that they want
to do here that they should have
probably done something you'd go and say
they put that stuff out on an actual PC
launch the way we all wanted that thing
to come out if they gave them the right
game they wouldn't have run right you're
right you're 100% right with that but if
they would have launched this game - the
PC and nobody looking from a resource
standpoint you
these dudes running through that code do
they deal let me tell you something
I'm not a fun UPC dude or the best dudes
in the world and if there's something
going on shady
in the background we would have never
found out we would have never found out
about ever worse but you found God X it
was the ratio to the shirt it was bad
because the guns they did the maths no
y'all pull the cord out and looked at
the code if somebody got cold eyes and
it was able to see we're alive of that
see that's what y'all went wrong Bungie
you're not greedy you're reaching for
those news that could actually lift up
the shirt thing is this when you look at
next thing one and you look at the
history and this gang start out flawed
and then it ended in season three all
these great systems all these things we
loved and we're sitting his destiny
plans like o - D - was gonna be lit
because they already got this as the
foundation that comes out and we like
but where's the heroic strike stop
where's this but how come the Ray
doesn't do this and how come everything
is casualized and how come Hawthorne's
giving out raid weapons and we're like
what's going on why's why our basic
things that were part of the core
destiny one experience missing at the
start of destiny - right and the way I
look at it is this to me
Bungie is this big they sign a ten-year
contract or whatever what Activision
write the way my theory works is that
Activision work their destiny wanna say
wait a minute what you guys have just
paying for it all you got them paying
for Z most you got them paying for it
yeah I've been paying for expansions but
you know it can kind of do more with
this model right as soon as destiny 2
comes out ever verse got a whole section
in the tower all of a sudden you know
Lou rewards like step number one used to
do the black spindle used to get that
the Simpsons say $14 is behind every
verse then if they did the math behind
it like there's no way to acquire these
items if you just play the game
the even if you mathematically an orange
e blessed you to get a different item
every single time you would still never
get every hour every item that's crazy
so the way I looked at it is one it got
casualized because they said okay we got
to get more people playing the game they
did not necessarily respect the hardcore
who actually stood by the game and loved
all those kind of hardcore systems
because they wanted to attract that
crowd
now the game comes out the casuals like
we had the discussion before the casuals
are gone Scott's not playing the
hardcore we carry the casuals yeah hold
them through the game except you lost
the hardcore you have no casual job
ultimately comes down to I see this
update and now it's like oh now they're
putting stuff back from testing one but
why is daddy pontus because one the
player base is dwindled to pathetic
levels there's love work you've got
famous streamers right now the PvP guy
the trick they're not playing destiny to
PvP they're now playing trials like the
way they used to these guys are on for
tonight pub G everything every other
game under this out out the Lord cactus
he's been on the show well look hack is
doing division video let you know what
is so the way I look at it he bounces is
now bunchy can come back to their
masters and said you see we did it your
way with forcing these microtransactions
over casual izing the game and now the
player base is going so now
they have the position to go to
Activision and say hey we gotta change
this and you got to give us the green
light to change it back and now I'm
getting the stuff from destiny one bad
but the problem is to be too little too
late because if you pissed off the hawk
cause that much you know what's the
incentive time to come back me
personally I loved SD so much I'm like
sinister I'm going to play it I like the
master what's up I'm wit Lord King I'm
saying I actually like the master I
thought that actually kept me going like
now I'm at a point with destiny each
update I look for a little thing I have
like set dates
okay next Tuesday faction rather I'm
looking forward to it because I want
that gear like did I get her one I do my
thing and then I jump off that's what
that's the two is for me right now are
you there if not solve gets jumping yeah
I'm here now well I like how you know
they're changing a lot of this stuff
around I do like how the reading 686 it
kind of caught me off guard a little bit
but are they breeding 6v6 back entirely
and replace 6lu six is back that's
replacing 44 is that it so no we're
adding it in additional so that's I was
like the question is is it coming back
for something just like rift or it's
more of an objective mode where you need
more people because 4v4 on rift I think
that's going to be really high scoring
six playlists we're bringing 6v6 PvP to
destiny - in addition to the current
four before game modes that's a list not
lists yes it's playlist that is correct
a playlist is multiple things anyways
yeah no III just let's go at it it's
cool if I really own destiny strikers
have no need for the game anymore
I'm going to play this next expansion
because I've already paid for it but
like they better have something crazy
because I'm about to raid it's like mmm
I don't care but the PvP school I get on
there but most of the time I'm on there
to play a raid and someone can tell me
to play question do you by destiny 3 or
does destiny three even come out I mean
Destiny's definitely
Destinee three there's no doubt in my
mind that games coming out if they don't
show me a significant improvement
between now and then probably not mm-hmm
now well here's the question um because
we know there's another raid later
coming which we know you're not a fan of
um here's the thing like is it going to
have to take their taken King style
expansion in September for you to take
it seriously because it won't be on the
Leviathan the more I know you hate the
Leviathan with these Ray laters
I don't want to even see the inside of a
sat the other side of the range you know
they're probably 3f oh my gosh like see
look what you guys made me do like I was
in a good mood and now I'm with
fustrated look like they need to fix the
raids there's no denying if there's no
going around and think like it just
feels fake to him it's fake the
Leviathan is lie the forest is a lie vr
Osiris lives there
and you go play multiplayer with him
sometimes it okay in the in the forest
yeah like that would have been okay but
the fact that it's like there's like
literally nothing connecting going from
the last mission of Osiris it's everyone
gotta email those like yo it's like
fighting cabal like the whole big Rhino
said story was in conjunction and then
at the very end you go from fighting the
Cabal to hearing calles to not hearing
Calais and fighting backs
once oh my gosh like some of the
mechanics were fun but it was the first
time that the ILP wouldn't did that raid
we got today the boss the boss how many
times do we white that much maybe maybe
seven times that's that's
overestimating like.we by maybe seven
times so basically you don't like these
they feel like miniature rate experience
is not a full-blown rage
so that's automatically play crota they
promise they promise I don't know where
I heard I don't know if it was a dream
or something
that they said a week and all these old
raids back I'm still waiting for that
I'm waiting for my vote the glass
remastered I'm waiting for that last
question had a coma for passing soffit
finish this thing off um you you with
the updates as far as the very specific
stuff isn't well wasn't any besides the
race specific stuff they said they're
adding was there anything on the in at
least okay I didn't expect that that has
me a little interested Oh Holly you know
armor drops and exclusive sit to the
raids it's like cool I can play the raid
and get a couple more things here's the
thing I don't want to play the rate
gotcha
the rate is whack it's literally you go
from a giant like spring thing where
they shoot you in outer space to a room
where you walk in this little gas stage
so your main issues the raid led you
you'd like callous no you like the
callous raid you like the Leviathan the
first yeah the raid was okay but like
and I told you from multiple times that
you know Leviathan was cool but it was
definitely not on my top three of the
right but this one is crota that for the
people who is watching this podcast they
don't play destiny that's like saying
like the worst game you possibly could
think of in your favorite franchise that
you kid it on all the time it's that
game gotcha
okay fair enough lost Ovilus anchor this
thing i know we've gone over but this
was a big one and i had to had to guess
on you are the casual anchor appearance
of opinion of our ranting and our oval
emotional selves i feel for you
crackheads me
you just haven't you just can't bring
yourself to walk away we have
withdrawals and we go back play the
[ __ ] and if we step away and we like
why do we play that day it's like I
can't excuse the first part of the raid
and how easy it was and how simplistic
every mechanic was in the game just
because them bought the mechanics to
fight the boss we're kind of cool this
is the time we have to walk away full
for life can't we got the ring on we
can't walk away the t-shirt wrapping off
a box of chocolates on the table
specially sorry a little bit I need to
be me to show me the way show me one day
this abusive relationship would change
that
at one point you had a question for all
of us yeah this off with that question
right but let me just give my overall so
the the the RPG elements the upgrading
elements the Lu elements has always been
stuff that appeal to me most about this
game the shooting is obviously great but
the upgrading and stuff that's what's
always like you know got me hooked into
it so yeah the the master works weapons
is cool stuff I'm glad that there are
gonna apply it to uh to armor I always
thought that you know as soon as I saw
that I said yeah appliance arming would
be cool the same thing with the exotics
like you have to make exotics matter
because they don't matter like most
people get their exotics just infuse
their legendaries and that's it
so don't have to matter um beyond that
like everything else I can't really
speak on I never hadn't used with I like
the way I'm crucible was I never played
in 6v6 so I don't know what I'm missing
so that's something but I definitely to
experience that but but my thing is this
and and King touched upon it with is are
you purchasing a destiny 3 this is just
definitely gonna be a destiny 3 right
and it's gonna be a death there's gonna
be a destiny 3 let's say 2020 right if
by the time you get to destiny 3 let's
say this game has been you know
quote-unquote where you want it to be
for a year at that point right I can say
for a year it's been where you guys are
happy with it and what do you think
destiny 3 is when it comes out is it is
it the game that you want it to be
starting out and then prove upon that
because the thing is the way the way
these updates are being presented now it
seems like Activision said you know what
we're wrong here you guys take the Rings
mm-hmm but when there's money involved
and the money the money involved now has
it's come back to them repeat the
playerbase and people on so now Bungie
has the argument to Activision to say
look can we do it back the way we wanted
to do it you know say and now us we have
in these updates these big development
updates and all of a sudden now they're
transparent right my thing is this if
and you guys have stated this before if
it is too little too late
and the playerbase doesn't come back be
ready for destiny 3 to be the same mmm
be ready for Activision to once again be
like nah you gotta try to figure out how
to put it differently uh I'll hide it
differently but we still need to get
this in there but here's the thing law
so you've got anthem coming
you've got the division has already
confirmed not only think 1.8 has been
great I'm hearing rave reviews the
vision is already confirmed they working
on a secret which is what I'm interested
in right now new engine whatever
whatever so you've got to major in it I
know he has got their issues but anthem
got positive reception and supposing I
doubt it comes out at the end of this
year but you know just remember that I
know I'm not quick to call it the
destined killer like everyone else is
saying I know who's behind that Matty eh
I ain't willing to st. and what there is
sentiment there people who are like I am
done with destiny anthem is a game that
got me the most hype I remember when
when they had them trailer Kato me me
and one attic was arguing people are I
might not be you know into that destiny
life right now but I'm not gonna go out
there say that you have one one scale of
one of those little suits that you have
to the rest are about microtransactions
you start it up you could you do the
first mission there so ok now you have
access to the first area we just need to
99 which is worse to you guys 3 let's
say it's it's not you know whatever
destiny to ends up being right it's
something brand-new but they're
promising it but it they say it's gonna
be for the hardcore right you guys buy
into it or you guys just want what you
want are you getting me we're gonna buy
it regardless to see what it is
if Bungie 1 alright here's the key if
Bungie wants to save themselves around
the anthem time mm-hmm
give us some type of black spindle quest
hidden quest that people don't know
about where the squares are his stuff
that's lacking this is where these guys
like you know player unknown and all the
more they give out that information I'm
hitting information and he draws people
back into the game but like oh look this
was hidden behind this wall and you
gotta check this whatever now I know
they haven't done it they need to put it
in if it's not in there put it in now
before it's too late
I don't think so um I don't think it's
gonna be how we want it to be like um
Laurie Bonta says are they gonna give
you all the Lucar okay oh okay
this is this is old content they making
it new right that's called a stripper
content right so they're giving you all
the stripper content it's recycled yeah
they stripped it down and they give me
the TV back right so they give me on the
stripper content and they puttin it back
inside destiny - alright so now when
destiny tool is fully realized that what
its gonna be destiny 1.5 right okay now
are you gonna get Destiny 1.5 when y'all
make destiny three are they're gonna
blow everything up and have cake come
out and say we ate that like cookies
cuz he's dead put this fool in front of
the camera and forget all your weapons
forget your clothes make your face and
no it has to it has to be a blow-up
thing because sovereign sovereign if
they say that in the beginning you have
to justify something you will part three
is that like halo 1 halo 2 halo 3 where
the story the vex come and blow up the
vote well they would delete the vault
never existed back in time and they made
sure volts didn't exist
wait crazy over like Bacchus Lord coming
through and that strong destiny before
we get into outro just uh any poll of
the week
let's get that rose so the new
appropriate people this week with the
tremendous success of the switch from a
sales and mindshare perspective is
Nintendo getting a pass by continuing to
port or remaster Wii U games like mario
kart mario tennis hyrule warriors etc to
the switch a yes pure cash grab no new
IPS be no it's smart the majority did
not buy a Wii U or C don't care as long
as they announced that smash brothers
question those are the choices please
Rock the ILP vote in the Twitter polls
will be up when it goes up
shout-out to Lord sinister and Lord
advances on this desk leader guru
talking gaming let's start off with our
main Lord sinister his debut with
channel 5 veteran where can people find
you you know you're doing them streams
so something yeah I do a little bit of
streaming here I'm mixer sinister
underscore x2 I do I'm not really on
Twitter sometimes on Twitter it's a
sinister x2 poems pwn essence and always
find me near or around some channel 5
member talking with them come join us
get a knife fall in get a raid in
whatever what's that what's that xbox
loud profile was that was the profile
sinister x2 no doubt we still wanna
mixing still doing them twitch streams
no doubt Lord advances the night for
solo esta hunter my man wicked about
people find you thanks for coming
through excellent oh absolutely yeah I
always appreciate the invite and thanks
for letting me always be a part of this
it's always a little insane which is
exactly boy ya know you can find me
pretty much Eve on ttis everywhere so EB
Ont is on Twitter twitch YouTube all of
that's pretty much the same everywhere
it's kind of a weird name but at least
work it works out so I guess I'm a geek
you guys go to my youtube channel hit me
up there I am working on my review on
all of this you'll hear my ramblings for
probably you have I can't I can't get a
script shorter than that so it's gonna
be a long one hello but you see how long
to show it because it is what house I
knew it was gonna be a we really
appreciate your perspective and all the
stuff you got cooking on the channel so
make sure you guys hit them up check all
that good stuff out yo so we're gonna do
these outros Lord addict wicked to find
people you put em down you ready to do
any kind of gaming Xbox Live ps4 it's
all room to kill but on Steam its gaming
at it so you find me on youtube gaming
addict on me you know any kind of media
outlet its gaming at it mmm-hmm down low
down Lord sovereign we're gonna find
people find you PSN being sovereign and
Lords
IOP on twitter and big shout out the
Sinister for finally showing his face
Martin's family coming back always
appreciated no and of course the premium
access game a la king making a piping
Vanya you can find me on everything
um boxes thank you for coming through I
had that big question for you as far as
you know I was I really wanted to know
if you sold it to be honest with you and
I know I don't get a chance to play with
you because you play on PlayStation and
I will be me on in the game on too many
platforms you wonder on the PC you'll
find me there to fix my PC this week
power source problem but guys i'll
sinister I'm so happy that you showed up
and you know I had to give you a little
bit of ribbon but that's my brother to
death do us part that's how it goes but
yo great show I had a great time with
you guys and yes these shirts are coming
we're just working out the technical
stuff guys I saw it post the og t-shirt
I know Requin yo I know I know it goes
perfect with that belt again wanted to
shout out to our guests like I said
Laurie Barnes don't sinister you
definitely be seeing them more as well
you know this won't be the last time it
was always good to have them on the show
do thanks for everyone in the chat it
was completely lit it actually rocking
with us during the Destiny talk I was
surprised it wasn't much drop off people
Rock yeah I was impressed I'm very proud
you know we initially started off as a
destiny podcast of big things in the
community happen we like to talk about
it so again thank you for hitting that
like and then subscribe to ILP and all
the inner circle network media outlets
YouTube iTunes and SoundCloud make sure
you check those out those will be going
up later on this afternoon and all that
support really helps
so I know like I said thanks for rocking
us with a little bit over I hope
everybody enjoys a Sunday get to those
playoffs games and we're gonna end this
thing now peace